Falsch einsortiert. Und ihr steigt jetzt alle auf Mastodon um, habt ihr gesagt?
Ne, wir haben schon gerade festgestellt, es ist alles Müll. Scheiße und stinkt?
Nein.
Nein?
Die Implementierung ist Scheiße und stinkt.
YouTube Premium heißt, diese Kapitelmarke startet, als du YouTube Premium eingeführt hast. So, jetzt sind wir allgemein da. Ich hab jetzt auch noch mal geguckt. Ich hab mir eigentlich auch das gleiche gekauft. Ich hab mir eigentlich mehr oder weniger dasselbe Auto nochmal, ein neuer gekauft. Ich dachte ja und hoffte immer, dass...
Und ich denke mir so, NEIN!
Ich bin da halt auch wirklich so, boah! Und das Kind guckt sich halt so, öh? Ich dachte mir so, nee ey, kann jetzt nicht dein Ernst sein. Versuch es grad zu verstehen und du legst auf Lösung anzeigen. Da war ich so ein bisschen genervt. Ja und in dem anderen Raum gab es so eine Ausstellung über alle Cypher-Machines, die sie so im Weltkrieg benutzt hatten. Und das war halt auch super spannend, sehr viel erklärt.
Da ist schon eine Menge zu holen. Ich war mit dieser Bombe, mir fehlte in diesem ganzen, wie in allen Museen fehlte mir mal, so ein bisschen so ein interaktives Element. Da sind halt einfach keine Leute, die man fragen kann. Alles wird dir von irgendwelchen Tafeln herunter erzählt und wenn dann irgendwas zweideutig ist, dann wird es halt schwierig. So, jetzt sag ich dir, welchen Fehler ihr gemacht habt.
Nicht ins Computer History Museum gehen.
Ihr seid nicht in das Computer History Museum gegangen. Also nochmal, mit Keynes, ein relativ langweiliger Ort, Bletchley Park, schönes Areal und dort ist halt einerseits eben dieses Museum zu den früheren Aktivitäten. Dieses, ja ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es nennen soll, Campus trifft es nicht so richtig. Also dieses Zentrum halt, wo dieses, wie nennen sie das? Die Crypto, was weiß ich, die Cypher, wie haben sie denn das genannt? Ist auch alles mega heroisch. Und wenn man da irgendwie so als Deutscher durchgeht, dann denkt man sich ja auch immer so ein bisschen so, oh Leute, echt.
Ja und vor allem so das SS Räumchen, was sie da so nachgebaut haben, wo du halt wirklich so daneben stehst, da ist auch ein Fehler glaube ich drin, weil sie eine Werbung von einem Bier drin haben, wo drauf steht, gebraut seit 1948 oder kurz danach, also wo der Krieg schon zu Ende war. Und du dachtest, zahlen, passen nicht so? Ein bisschen strange auf jeden Fall.
Ja, da haben sie halt irgendwie auch ein komisches Verhältnis zu. Da werden die irgendwie nicht, das dauert einfach noch mal ein paar Generationen, glaube ich. Auf demselben Areal gibt es aber dann noch das National Museum of Computing, TNMOC. Und wer von euch da mal vorbeikommt, also schaut euch nicht nur Bletchley Park an, schaut euch unbedingt dieses Museum an. Und ich bin nach dem EMF Camp dahingefahren, dazu kommen wir gleich noch, und dann so auf dem Weg dahin, hab ich dann mal so gekluckt, ok, wie sind die Öffnungszeiten denn genau? Und dann stell ich fest, so hat nicht geöffnet an dem Tag, wo ich irgendwie eingeplant habe. Das ist so fass, das ist nicht euer Ernst. Jetzt hab ich irgendwie wochenlang diese Reise geplant, um an diesem Dienstag da zu sein und dann hat es nicht geöffnet. Und stellte aber fest, Glück im Unglück, es gibt Führungen. Schnell Ticket geklickt und dann dahin marschiert. Hat genau gepasst, irgendwie vormittags Bletchley Park und dann läuft es ein paar Meter weiter und dann pünktlich zu dieser Führung. Ja, dann kommt da so ein Graubad und es waren nur drei andere Teilnehmer noch mit dabei. Und los ging's. Und ich war ja schon ein paar Mal da. Ich kannte eigentlich alles. Ich hab alles schon mal gesehen. Aber dann hab ich festgestellt, das ist genau das, was man da machen will. Man will so eine Führung klicken, das ist das Geilste überhaupt. Weil da hast du dann zwei, drei Stunden deinen Privat-Nerd. Und diese Leute machen das ja alle freiwillig. Und die blühen so auf, wenn du irgendwie Fragen stellst. Das ist einfach irre. Fing natürlich an hier, blablabla. Und was mir da auch erst klar geworden ist, ist, dieses Bletchley Park war nicht nur irgendwie jetzt so ein Militärprojekt. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie die Deutschen in den Abgrund geschubst und so. Und wir sind ganz stolz auf uns. Sondern da wurde mir erst so richtig klar, durch diese Krypto, die sie da gemacht haben, durch dieses ganze, dieser Bedarf, Maschinen zu bauen, um Krypto zu bekämpfen, das ist die Basis der britischen Computerentwicklung. Und die ersten Computer, die sie da gebaut haben, und da haben sie ja dann auch schöne Nachbildungen da stehen, zum Beispiel diesen Kolossus, das waren halt alles so dedizierte Maschinen mit festen Programmen, die nur dafür gedacht waren, möglichst schnell diesen ganzen Kryptogramm durchzurechnen. Irre Konstruktion, also allein dieser Kolossus-Computer ist Wahnsinn, weil die hatten ja damals das Problem, es gab keinen RAM, du hattest irgendwie keinen Speicher. Die Maschinen mussten mehr oder weniger alles immer in Realtime einfüttern und irgendwo mussten diese Informationen ja sein. Und dann hatten sie diese Daten, diese ganzen Zahlenketten, die sie überprüfen wollen, auf Lochstreifen. Dieser Kolossus-Computer ist so, dass die Lochstreifen durchlaufen und da haben sie nämlich diesen ersten optischen Lochstreifen-Abtaster gebaut, der Welt, der quasi, wenn der Lochstreifen vorbei fährt, dann wird durch das Licht, das da reingeht, durch diese Optokopplung im System, in dem Moment dieser Wert elektronisch eingeblendet und damit wird gerechnet. Und wenn das nächste Loch vorbeikommt, wird schon der nächste gerechnet. Das war also quasi synchronisiert. Und dieses permanent im Kreis laufende Lochstreifen-Abtaster, das ein paar Meter lang ist, wo die Daten drauf sind, die immer wieder durchgerechnet werden sollen, lief einfach die ganze Zeit im Kreis dran vorbei und lieferte quasi Daten in meinen Realtime, sodass du gar nichts speichern musstest. Es gab zwar Register, aber eben keinen richtigen Speicher. Irre! Und so hat sich das dann irgendwie alles entwickelt und ich konnte natürlich den Typen da ausfragen, bis zum Getno, und der war dann auch, glaube ich, ganz glücklich mit meinen Nachfragen, weil ich wollte es natürlich dann mal ganz genau wissen. Und dann kam er dann irgendwie in so einen Raum und dann stand die Maschine da, die vorher im Bletchley Park stand. Da haben die nämlich, die machen so Rebuilding-Projects da, das ist halt das Coole. Die haben nicht nur alte Scheiße, sondern die ganze alte Scheiße, die es nicht mehr gab, bauen die danach. Unter anderem halt auch diese Bombs, also das sind diese Drehzylinder, mit denen sie quasi die Enigma-Code gecrackt haben. Und während du in dieser...
Die Polen haben die erste Maschine rübergebracht.
Die haben die ersten Schwachstellen gefunden. Aber diese Maschine war quasi ein Touringswerk. Aber in der Hütte, wo du warst, da war ja nur Fotos davon und so ein paar spielerische Nachbildungen. Aber die haben dort eben die richtigen Bomben nachgebaut. Also die original Maschine nachgebaut. Die steht da. Und da stand da halt noch so ein Nerd davor. Und ich so, ich hab da mal ne Frage. Und der glühte gleich wieder irgendwie in allen Farben. Und unsere Führung, die eigentlich an der Stelle mehr oder weniger dran vorbeigehen wollte, haben uns dann einfach nochmal eine dreiviertel Stunde nur darüber unterhalten. Der hat dann gleich richtig weit ausgeholt. Und so war das und hier und Details und wirklich jedes Bit. Nerdporn, also wirklich grandios. Wenn ihr da seid, bitte National Museum of Computing bucht euch so eine Tour und lasst euch da durch.
Es ist irre.
Ja, vor allem versucht das, also versucht in der Tat als erstes dieses krasse Museum, dieses Computer History zu gucken. Als erstes, weil das ist glaube ich...
Genau, erstmal Bletchley Park und dann lacht das an.
Nee, andersrum würde ich sagen.
Ja, ist eigentlich egal, aber es passt vom Timing ja meistens besser.
Genau und das Einzige, was cool ist, man kann mit der Karte von Bletchley Park, da schreibt man seinen Namen drauf, und man darf ein Jahr, nachdem man es ausgestellt hat, noch immer, also ein Jahr lang dieses Museum besuchen.
Das ist generell in England so?
Ach, das ist generell so. Guck mal einer an. Hier kauft man eine Dauerkarte für... Ja, und da überlege ich jetzt halt, ob ich im November vielleicht nochmal hinfahre und halt mir erst das Computer History Museum anschau, und danach nochmal bei Bletchley Park reingehe und das versuche, meinen Frieden mit diesem Ort zu schließen.
Da komme ich gerne mit.
Ja, aber ich mein, es war, also ich fand, man muss diesen Ort ja auch mal gesehen haben und da rumgelaufen sein, so als Nerd fand ich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall super. Also die haben auch mehr geiles Zeug. Du siehst halt auch diese ganzen 80er Jahre. Da waren ja die Briten noch ganz weit mit Sinclair und BBC Computer und dieser ganzen Kram. Da steht da alles rum. Die haben da eine Cray rumstehen. Die haben diesen großartigen The Witch Computer. Der ist ein Horwell Decathlon Computer. Ein Dezimal Computer, der mit so Dezimal, mit Decatrons, mit so Dezimalröhren gearbeitet hat. Und das Geile ist, du stehst da vor, diese Röhren schauen dich alle an. Und du siehst, diese Röhren haben quasi immer so ein Zehner Zustand. Also sie können einen von zehn Werten annehmen. Also nicht binär, sondern halt Dezimal. Und da leuchtet es dann halt auch immer. Das heißt, du schaust von vorne auf diese Maschine und während diese Maschine arbeitet, siehst du jedes Bit, jedes, also jedes, ja, jede Dezimalstelle sozusagen.
Jedes Dez.
Während sie, jeden Rezi, was da irgendwo ist, läuft in dem Moment. Also ich hatte das früher gesehen. Derzeit lief die Maschine gerade nicht, da war irgendwas kaputt. Aber das ist an sich schon mal eine tolle Experience. Gibt es auch sicherlich noch ein paar ganz coole Videos. Ich hab noch nicht so viel geguckt. Vielleicht könnte der Chat mal gucken. The Witch National Museum of Computing.
Oder der Harwell Decathlon.
Genau, ich hab hier auch nochmal für den Chat hier der Harwell Computer. Und das ist einfach wunderschön anzuschauen. Und es ist auch wieder so eine Maschine, wo du so davor stehst und kannst dir einfach direkt beim Laufen zuschauen. Übrigens, und das wäre vielleicht für den zweiten Ausflug, auch nochmal ein Tipp. Mir haben sie dann erzählt, es gibt dann auch noch ein geiles Computermuseum in Cambridge. Und da sind sie halt dadurch, dass da arm ist, sehr viel mehr moderne. Also da geht sehr viel mehr in unsere Gegenwart rein und in die Vergangenheit der aktuellen Gegenwart. Und da gäbe es auch so eine Nachbildung eines Prozessors, wo auch jemand sich die Mühe gemacht hat, jeden Zustand mit LEDs anzuzeigen. Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, gibt es da auch so eine Art CPU, die langsam abläuft, wo du dann sozusagen Schritt für Schritt die kompletten CPU-Funktionalitäten nachschauen kannst. Das ist natürlich der totale Bitorgasmus.
Das muss ich mir unbedingt anschauen.
Fall Lohnen da in diesem England da drüben.
Ja, dann waren wir in Westengland.
In East Norr.
Genau, beim East Norr Castle, beim East Norr Obelisk. Du bist ja noch zum Obelisk hoch.
Ich bin noch auf den Obelisk hoch, genau. Aber das Castle ist ein Fake Castle, das hat Will erzählt. Als sich irgendein reicher Top ist, das mal gekauft. Nee, hingebaut im Ende des 19. Deswegen ist es ein Fake Castle, das ist kein richtiges.
Sieht aber castleig genug aus, wenn du mich fragst. Also wir waren auf dem Electromagnetic Field, im EMF Camp, das fand zum vierten Mal statt. Das fand zum ersten Mal an dieser Location statt, wie sich herausstellte, das war die Location, wo sie schon immer hin wollten, wo sie aber in den letzten Jahren nie eine Möglichkeit gefunden haben, Internet hinzubekommen. Und jetzt haben sie es geschafft, eine Glasfaser hinzulegen und deswegen gab es auch Netz. Das hat super funktioniert. Das Gelände ist speziell, würde ich mal sagen.
Es liegt an einem Hang und alles ist total schräg.
Das gesamte Gelände ist ein einziger Hang. Und da wo kein Hang ist, da ist ein Wasserloch.
Genau, also es gibt nicht viele Stellen, die so halbwegs eben sind. Komischerweise ging das irgendwie am Ende alles, aber es ist schon irgendwie strange. Es ist ein stranger Ort, da finden wohl viele Festivals statt. Die Briten kennen es nicht anders, da in England ist irgendwie alles gewählt.
Naja, das ist vielleicht wie mit so Kühen, die am Hang stehen.
Ich glaube, alles wo es gerade ist, da haben sie einen Fußballplatz hingebaut. Das EMF Camp ist ein tolles Camp. Ich hatte ja glaube ich vom letzten Mal hier schon berichtet und die Orga konnte einem echt leid tun, weil bei diesem Event ist im Vorfeld so ziemlich alles schiefgegangen, was irgendwie schiefgehen konnte und zwar auf den letzten Metern. Bis dahin war wohl alles super. Aber dann in der Woche des Aufbaus kamen irgendwie nicht alle Zelte. Sie kamen entweder gar nicht oder es kamen die falschen Zelte, eine beliebige Mischung da draus. Dann waren sie schon in totaler Panik, weil sie diesen Zeltaufbau nicht erreichen konnten. Wir reden nicht von irgendwelchen kleinen Zelten, sondern von den großen Vortragselten. Dann haben sie schon eine andere Firma angerufen, die dann noch ihr Zelt gebracht hat. Dann kamen aber die anderen trotzdem und mussten jetzt irgendwie alle bezahlen. Also ein totales Chaos. Die sind so auf dem Zahnfleisch gelaufen, die konnten einem echt nur noch leid tun. Haben sie aber dafür, finde ich, mit Würde und Haltung durchgezogen. Am Ende war auch alles gut, weil alle waren begeistert, denn das EMF Camp war toll. Also es war ein wirklich guter Event, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Und ich weiß nicht, was fällt dir noch ein, zum EMF Camp. Ich poste hier mal so einen Link mit schönen Fotos, dann können sich hier alle im Chat schon mal Gedanken machen. Linus war auch da, hat schöne Drohnen-Pictures gemacht von oben.
Ist jetzt glaube ich auf der Titelseite vom EMF Camp Org.
Obwohl das ja alles so verboten war.
Ja, es war eigentlich strengstens verboten.
Aber sah dann doch geil aus.
Ja, was mir wirklich so im Hinterkopf geblieben ist, dass es halt viel zu kurz ist. Und dieser Zeit, dieser Kürze der Zeit, ist man sich nicht so bewusst, wenn man so eine Badge in die Hand bekommt. Und es gab halt eine Badge beim EMF Camp mit GSM und Bluetooth, sowie verschiedene Sensoren, Lichttemperatur, dann dieses magnetische...
Ich hab die da hinten in der Schublade. Ich hol die mal kurz raus.
Dann haben wir so einen Magnetfeldsensor. Also eine Menge geiler Scheiß. Aber zum Beginn hat die halt nicht ganz stabil funktioniert und man musste die halt ständig irgendwie resetten. Und wenn man dafür entwickelt hat, war das jetzt auch nicht so klar, ob das dann immer so richtig läuft mit den Apps, die man da drauf entwickelt hat. Und wenn man halt nur so ein begrenztes Wochenende... Also wir reden hier beim EMF Camp von wirklich 48 Stunden, kann man eigentlich sagen. Also man fängt halt freitags irgendwann an und hört am Sonntagabend irgendwann auf. Und wenn du dann am Samstagmittag, morgens, morgens war es sogar, dieses Batch in die Hand bekommst und dir einen Keks drüber freust, weil das Ding lief halt mit MicroPython, das hieß die Einstiegshürde, da was drauf zu coden, war sehr, sehr gering. Ja, da war dann der Samstag ganz schön rum. Ich glaube, ich habe keinen Vortrag am Samstag gesehen. Ich habe Kaffee getrunken und das Batch von hinten bis vorne versucht zu verstehen.
Sehr löblich. Ich habe da nicht ganz so viel Energie drauf gebracht. Ich habe es manchmal in Betrieb genommen, aber nicht wirklich drauf rumgehackt. Das Gute an dem EMF-Batch-Konzept ist ja, die setzen jetzt schon mindestens seit dem letzten Jahr eine direkte Weiterentwicklung fort. Das heißt, das war jetzt Tilda MK4, also die vierte Version. Und das mit dem MicroPython, das hatten sie schon vor zwei Jahren gemacht. Im Prinzip bedient sich das neue System genauso wie das alte, nur dass sie jetzt den Overkill gemacht haben und dann ein komplettes GSM-Telefon noch mit drauf integriert haben. Das ist natürlich irgendwie alles ganz geil. Aber ich muss an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal meine Kritik loswerden, die ich generell an dieser Batch auf Computerveranstaltungen, Bewegungen kritisiere. Also wir hatten das ja auch auf dem House-Communication-Camp. Da gab's die Rocket. Dann gab's letztes Mal diese Rocket mit SDR drauf, mit dem Software Defined Radio. Auch dieses Teil hat jetzt irgendwie ja, ich bin ein GSM-Telefon, da kann man eine SIM-Karte reinstecken. Toll, toll, toll, toll, toll.
Das muss man dazu sagen, es hat natürlich auf dem Camp nicht funktioniert.
Das ist das eine. Sie haben sich die Mühe gemacht, ein GSM-Netz aufzubauen. Das lief so la la und eigentlich nicht so richtig. Also man hatte nicht so viel Spaß dran. Im Prinzip funktioniert das auch. Das ist so eine merkwürdige SIM-Karte. Wie hieß dieser Provider noch gleich? Und da kriegt man so eine SIM-Karte und hat dann irgendwie free, nicht free data, also hast du das überall.
Das ist 1 Megabyte.
1 Megabyte pro Monat.
Das ist mehr so IoT. Ich finde das irre. Ja, also Leute machen sich da die Mühe, die entwickeln das, dann machen die sich vor allem die Mühe, noch die ganzen Unternehmen dazu zu bekommen, das zu sponsern, zu bauen. Im Prinzip ist das auch separat bezahlt. Man bezahlt es nicht mit dem Eintritt. Sponsoring ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Das hielt sich aber auf dieser Veranstaltung wirklich sehr in Grenzen.
Es ist kein Download-Sponsors-Segile.
Ja, weil er jetzt das WLAN hier nicht kennt.
Das hab ich eben gerade versucht beizubringen.
Ja, gut, vielleicht... Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist alles beeindruckend und das ist toll. Ich finde es grundsätzlich gut, dass es sowas gibt. So, jetzt heißt das Ding tilde MK4 und es wird als Badge bezeichnet. Was ist ein Badge? Ein Badge ist etwas, was man sich irgendwie an die Brust klebt und wo ein Name drauf steht. Diese ganzen hochkomplexen Teile hier wurden letzten Endes im Wesentlichen dafür verwendet. Es gab auch andere Entwicklungen. Irgendjemand hat einen Imsy-Catcher darauf implementiert. Und was war das andere Irre, was damit noch gemacht wurde?
Ich hoffe nicht, dass du das von den Holländern meinst.
Von dem MK4.
Ja, aber die Holländer haben noch eine App gemacht, wo im Prinzip die holländische Flagge und irgendwas mit Dutch VIP drauf stand. Das gab es dann auch im App Store. Daran kannst du dich nicht mehr erinnern.
Nein, kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern. Es gab noch eine, ah ja, genau, Bluetooth. Genau, hier kommt es gerade. Ein Bluetooth-Scanner, ein Speaker. Genau, man konnte das Ding quasi als Bluetooth-Lautsprecher betreiben. Das ist schon irre und das finde ich irgendwie eine tolle Sache. Alles super. Allerdings, und das betrifft jetzt sozusagen auch unser Camp im nächsten Jahr. Was ich einfach vermisse und da sind eigentlich die Briten schon weiter als wir noch. Die Dinger funktionieren eigentlich nicht so richtig als das, wie sie bezeichnet werden. Als Batch. Also als Batch taugen die eigentlich kaum. Da wird dann halt irgendwie ein Name angezeigt und das leuchtet auf dem Bildschirm und damit kann man dann durch die Gegend laufen. Laufen hurra! Toll. Also dafür muss man jetzt aber keine monatelange Elektronikentwicklung betreiben und Telefone und SDR und was nicht alles noch mit da drauf machen. Wie gesagt, ich finde es gut, dass es solche Projekte gibt, die quasi für wenig Geld solche cool hackbaren Devices mit vielen Features rausbringen. Aber für einen Batch bräuchte es eigentlich was anderes. Deswegen wäre mein Wunsch, dass man auf so einer Veranstaltung, wenn man sowas schon machen will, ein Device baut, was nur ein Batch ist. Oder was im Wesentlichen nur ein Batch ist. Und wenn es noch irgendwelche weiteren Funktionen hat, also wenn es irgendwie kommuniziert etc. Dann sollte man sich darauf konzentrieren, Funktionen einzubauen, die auf der Veranstaltung auch wirklich einen Nutzen entwickeln. Und der die Leute dazu animiert, diesen Nutzen auch möglichst maximal zu nutzen. So, und dann muss man sich halt fragen, jetzt generell der Nerd-Fehler ist ja immer so, oh guck mal, wir haben hier geile Hardware, guck mal, was das alles für coole Bits durch die Gegend schieben kann. Und dann, da kann man sicherlich irgendwas Tolles mitbauen. Aber man denkt es quasi so von dem Engineering her, von dem es ist cool, weil es das und das hat. Aber was irgendwas hat, ist eigentlich für die Leute vollkommen uninteressant, für die Leute ist immer interessant, was kann ich damit machen? Also muss man das Ganze von der Anwendungsseite her entwickeln. Man muss sich erstmal fragen, was für ein Bedarf gibt es eigentlich auf so einer Veranstaltung? Was braucht man eigentlich? Und was vor allem in unserer Smartphone getriebenen Zeit brauche ich eigentlich von so einem Device, was mein Smartphone nicht leisten kann? Und da wird es dann halt schon knifflig, weil vieles ist halt auf dem Smartphone viel besser angelegt. Ich brauch nicht das Programm irgendwie auf so einem Teil, weil da mit meinen Knöpfen da durch zu navigieren auf so einem langsamen Gerät, das bringt nichts. Da hab ich eine Mobile-Webpage.
Das ist recht gemütlich unterwegs, das Teil, ja.
Oder ich bau so eine App, aber das bringt es einfach nicht. Sinnvoller wären halt andere Funktionen, wofür man sein Smartphone nicht nehmen würde oder wollen würde. Zum Beispiel ein EKG.
Kommt später.
Aber versteht ihr, was ich damit sagen möchte? Also, ich hab so ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht und ich hab das nicht, ich hab jetzt kein vollständiges Konzept erarbeitet oder so was. Ich hab nur mal angefangen, so darüber nachzudenken, was sind eigentlich die Probleme, die ich auf so einer Veranstaltung habe? Oder was sind so spielerische Elemente, die ich gerne vielleicht verfolgen würde, die sozial für mich auch akzeptabel sind, dass ich damit spielen würde? Und wo könnte mir so ein dedicated device helfen, wo ich aber mein Smartphone vielleicht nicht unbedingt für verwenden wollen würde? Dann muss man jetzt erstmal sagen, naja, das Ding muss vor allem erstmal als Batch gut funktionieren. Das heißt, es sollte ein Gehäuse haben, es sollte so einen Clip haben, man sollte es irgendwie gut an T-Shirt und Camots befestigen, die so, ich muss es gut ranklippen können, es muss halten können, ich muss es abnehmen können, gut verstauen können, vielleicht auch ein Bändchen drum machen, wie ich es um den Hals hängen möchte, aber dann sollte er irgendwie auch kompakt sein, damit diese riesen Teile, wie sieht denn das aus, als ob man die ganze Zeit mit so einem Mainboard spazieren.
Also ich hab das Mainboard spazieren gefangen, das war in der Tat ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, das sieht halt hackerisch aus, ne?
Ja, das sieht hackerisch aus, aber da kannst du auch ein altes Mainboard umhängen und dann bist du halt irgendwie wie so ein Electronic-Rapper.
Wie hast du mich nochmal bezeichnet?
Flava Flaff. Weißt du, wer Flava Flaff ist?
War das nicht irgendwas mit einer Uhr?
Ja, Flava Flaff war seine offizielle Rolle MC von Public Enemy. Und der fiel halt immer dadurch auf, dass er immer so riesige Uhren um seinen Hals hing. Und so kommt mir das halt einfach vor, wenn man da die ganze Zeit so ein Mainboard spazieren trägt. Das war irgendwie so eine elektronische Version von Flava Flaff. Nichts gegen Flava Flaff, das ist eine saugule Sau. Der Typ ist super und Public Enemy sollte man sowieso mal gehört haben. Das war echt Rap. Und wir hören meistens bitte nicht Flaff.
Wie denn dann? Flava Flaff?
Flaff?
Flava, ja Flava. Flava wie?
Abseits von dem, wie man das jetzt hier ausspricht oder auch nicht, was ganz cool war und was wirklich eine gute Idee ist, um Leute zum Spielen zu bewegen mit dieser Batchlist. Die hatten eine sehr, sehr gute Print, so ein kleines Booklet dazu gemacht. Sehr, sehr liebevoll gestaltet und sehr, sehr kurz und knapp gehalten. Wie man die Batch zusammenbaut, wie man die ersten Schritte auf ihr macht, wie man sich mit ihr überhaupt auch connecten kann vom Rechner her. Und das fand ich war eine sehr, sehr schöne Idee. Nicht nur dieses Jahr, du hast hier dieses Wiki. Das ist halt nett, aber meistens auch eher so hinten liegen gelassen worden. Und das, was sie sich da halt überlegt haben, so hast du ein kleines Häftchen dazu, kriegst irgendwie die ersten Schritte damit mit der Batch auf die Reihe, das fand ich schon ziemlich cool. Ja, also das könnte man sich auch mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Ja, gute Dokumentation bin ich dafür. Nur, wenn man jetzt halt über so einen Batch nachdenkt, dann möchte ich auch gerne, und das fände ich auch gerade mal, einen wichtigen Prozess, insbesondere für diese Nerd-Community, die einfach dieses vom User her Denken nicht Intos hat, nicht natürlich ausschwitzt, sich dem mal anzunehmen und mal wirklich über Anwendungen nachzudenken, die einfach sind, wo der Erfolg und der Fame, den man am Ende für einsammelt und die Coolness, wenn man es benutzt, nicht davon kommt, wie geil die Elektronik ist und was für ein cooler Stein und was man da theoretisch vielleicht irgendwie alles programmieren könnte, zwei Wochen nachdem die Veranstaltung vorbei ist, nicht danach das zu bemessen, sondern danach zu messen, wie viele Leute fangen an, das wirklich zu benutzen und spielerisch in diese Veranstaltung einzubringen. Ich lasse einfach mal so random ein paar Ideen fallen. Einerseits muss das Ding als Batch gut funktionieren. Also es muss irgendwie den Namen gut anzeigen, das heißt, es sollte irgendwie genug Möglichkeiten bieten, den Namen anzugeben und dann eben zu konfigurieren mit so, was weiß ich, zehn verschiedenen Seams, wie das irgendwie aussieht, Hintergrundbild, kleines Filmchen.
Tim, ich glaube, wir sind einfach ein bisschen zu lang. Langeweilig. Hallo, der Dude.
Wohl kein Mensch weiß, wovon ihr redet. Ja, das ist The Dude.
Das steht The Dude und guckt komisch und rührt dabei in seinem... Was trinkt der immer?
Moskau.
Nein.
Kapitelmarke.
Diese Kauppel, die man mal über User...
Ich bin auf dem Standpunkt, wenn du ein Badge-Brett-Zettel-Stift fertig, und wenn du hacken willst, mach halt ein Hackbrett und nenn es nicht Badge.
Aber trotzdem ist so ein elektronisches Badge eine coole Idee.
Ich halte es für unnötig.
Das vielleicht nicht.
Es könnte sein, dass es unnötig ist, aber man kann ja trotzdem mal drüber nachdenken, dass wenn man schon mal eins macht, dass man dann auch eins macht, was als Badge funktioniert.
Die meisten haben aber zu kleine Displays, um als Badge gut zu funktionieren.
Das Display, was da drauf ist, das ist so ein 320 x 240 Farbteil, oder? Reicht völlig aus.
Wir wollen Liquid Retina.
Ne, Super Retina. Entschuldige mal bitte. Ne, ich fände das Display in der Tat zu klein.
Ich will jetzt endlich mal meine Ideen loswerden.
Entschuldigung.
Also. Ich brauch nicht nur ein neues Badge, ich brauch ein neues Team. Kinder. Also, denk doch mal mit. Man hat so ein Badge. So, jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, das Ding hat ein ordentliches Gehäuse. Das heißt, es ist auch halbwegs stoßgeschützt. Tralala, tralala. So, jetzt baut man da so ein paar kleine Sensoren ein. Was weiß ich. Ein Beschleunigungs-Sensor würde, glaube ich, ziemlich viel Sinn machen. Dann könnte man zum Beispiel schon so Spiele machen, dass wenn das Badge hin und her wackelt, dass der Name auch immer gerade bleibt. So was zum Beispiel, dass man es immer gut lesen kann, selbst wenn du viel rumwackern kannst. Es ist auch egal, wie rum du es dran machst. So was, ja. Oder dass man halt auch irgendwie Visitenkarten austauschen kann, indem man die Dinge einfach aneinanderstößt. Und wenn das Ding in irgendeiner Form auch noch so eine Beacon-Funktionalität hat, also so auf Wunsch, dass man so einen Knopf macht und sagt, okay, ich will jetzt, dass meine Identität und oder meinen Standort bekanntgegeben wird, dass das Beacon sozusagen, also das Badge auch als Beacon funktioniert und damit auch signalisiert, wo bin ich denn jetzt hier auf dem Acker. Aber dass man so jederzeit mit einem Schalter Klack Privacy on, Klack Privacy off machen kann, sodass man von anderen Leuten gefunden werden kann. Sprich, man bildet sich automatisch auf einer Map an und wenn ich jetzt irgendwie meine Peergroup suchen will, dann sehe ich auf dem Badge auch genau, wo ich in etwa hingehen muss, um meine Peergroup zu finden. Ohne jetzt mit Smartphone und tra la la und so weiter arbeiten zu müssen. Nur lokal auf dieser Veranstaltung. Und added benefit, dass man sich vielleicht noch irgendwie –ja, ne, das ist eine andere Idee, die ich später mal vorlese. Das Mitteln ist noch zu weit. Aber so mal darüber nachzudenken. Was kann –fragt euch, was das Badge für euch tun.
Ganz wichtig, scrollen der Kalender muss auch noch drauf.
Also keine teuren Leuchtturmprojekte machen, sondern irgendwie geiler Scheiß. Einfach billig herzustellen, trotzdem sexy, mit ein paar coolen Features und mindestens einem Feature, wo die meisten Leute sagen, ja geil, allein deshalb muss ich mir das schon ranstecken.
Wir hatten das Thema ja auf dem IMF-Camp auf jeden Fall schon und ich dachte so, es gab mal so ein geiles, bescheuertes Nokia-Telefon. Also Nokia hat ja viele so ne Strangen-Telefone gebaut und sowas müsste man als Badge umfunktionieren. Und zwar folgendes. Und es gab noch ein anderes, aber da finde ich einfach nicht mehr, welches von den bescheuerten das war.
Ja, das war auch schon echt genial.
Eines der geilsten von denen, so diese Form. Das mit einem größeren Display. Und dann hast du deine Badge.
Dieses Nokia 7600, das war natürlich als Telefon vollkommen bekloppt.
Genau, aber als Badge ist es genau das Richtige. Eigentlich wusste Nokia schon viel früher, wie so eine Badge auszusehen hat.
Ja, nur dass es natürlich keinerlei Badge-Funktionalität da drauf hat.
Ja, dann muss man halt nochmal einen Run printen und dann macht man eine Software drauf und fertig.
Also ich sehe schon, Apple hat da auf jeden Fall noch eine Markennische zu besetzen. I-Batch.
I-Batch. Mit, mit, warte mal, was hatten wir jetzt?
Ja, der CCC hat da eine Markennische zu besetzen. Und man könnte sich zum Beispiel auch einfach dieser Tilder-Technologie schonmal annehmen und das einfach, was da schon entwickelt wurde, nehmen, weil da ist eine ganze Menge drauf, App Store und dieser ganze Bim Bim. Da muss man nicht alles wieder komplett neu erfinden. Man macht einfach ein Downsizing, schmeißt den ganzen Tor in Scheiß weg, macht ein paar nette Sensoren drauf und ab geht er, der Peter.
Und ein cooles Gehäuse. Marke Nokia.
Ich mein, das ist das Ding...
7600 heißt es.
Die GSM-Funktionalität ist ja vielleicht irgendwie ganz, ganz nice, aber viel wichtiger ist eigentlich die Tatsache, dass mit dem Stein ja auch Bluetooth kommt. Und das könnte durchaus sinnvoll sein. Was müssen wir noch erzählen?
Du hast einen Vortrag gehalten, den ich natürlich wirklich nicht gesehen habe, weil ich mit der Batch beschäftigt war. Und die mir aber anschauen wollte, obwohl ich nicht wusste, dass der Vortrag von dir ist. Ja, ich hab den Titel gesehen, das klingt aber gut. Und man sieht ja immer die Vorfragen.
Was war denn das Thema?
Na, ich hab einfach über Podcasting geredet. Worüber denn sonst? Ich hab mal... Also, wer, sagen wir mal, die Welt der Metaebene verfolgt, wird da verhältnismäßig wenig wirklich Neues, glaub ich, rauslesen. Weiß ich nicht so genau. Ich hab einfach mal versucht, Podcasting zu erklären, so from the ground up. Warum ist das eigentlich interessant? Und was kann da funktionieren? Und wie sollte man da rangehen? Wie werde ich ein erfolgreicher Podcaster, eine erfolgreiche Podcasterin, und das mal auf Englisch. Und ich war ganz zufrieden am Ende. Also ist irgendwie ganz gut gelaufen. Könnt ihr euch ja mal anschauen und kommentieren. So, EMF Camp, was war noch geil? Geil auf dem EMF Camp? Also das EMF Camp war dieses Mal ein bisschen...
Weil einer hier gesagt hat, was braucht man auf einem Camp? Und der sagte Dusche und die Duschen waren geil. Das war das einzige, was heiß war nachts.
Aber das ist doch ein sekundärer...
Ey, sorry, aber als Frau muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen, der Spaßfaktor auf jede Art von Camp nimmt für mich ab, wenn die sanitären Anlagen einfach für den Arsch sind.
Zu deiner Information, das ist auch bei Männern so.
Genau, aber ich finde, das sollte man mal wirklich sagen, das waren...
Ja, wir wollen doch jetzt nicht über das EMF Camp reden. Es hatte geile Duschen.
Es war halt echt ganz schön kalt nachts.
Ich finde das aber durchaus einen wichtigen...
Vielleicht mal so viel zum EMF Camp. Vor zwei Jahren habe ich ja hier schon mal berichtet, ist mir vor allem aufgefallen, wie anders dieses Camp ist. Diesmal ist mir vor allem aufgefallen, wie sehr sich das EMF Camp jetzt unseren Camps angenähert hat. Leute waren früh da, es gab viele Villages, es gab viele Zelte, wo Leute ihre eigene Action gemacht haben. Es war groß, es war auch eine Menge Platz da. Da hätten noch viel mehr Leute draufgepasst. Das war soweit schon mal ganz gut. Trotzdem hat es so ein bisschen seinen Charakter wieder gezeigt. Einerseits durch diese großartige englische Bar, wo es irgendwie so unheimlich viel Craft Beer gibt. Das hätte dir sehr gut gefallen, Roddy. Also wir haben da immer eine riesen Auswahl. Es ist halt alles englisches Bier.
Das stärkste Bier war am schnellsten weg. Das war auch das einzige, was ich irgendwie dann mal einen Schluck von nehmen konnte.
Und man kann überall mit Apple Pay bezahlen.
Selbst mit Kreditkarte und hier...
Alles elektronisch.
Microwave wollte ich gerade sagen, das ist es. Aber hier nicht. Wie heißt das?
Da ist das schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren normal. Oder? Der Racetrack war geil. Ich poste mal dieses Video, das ist so grandios.
Aus Heuballen ein Racing-Track für Elektromobile. Oder war noch alles Elektromobile?
Es war alles so elektrische Seifenkisten, würde ich mal sagen.
Und wer auf dem einen oder anderen Chaos-Event war, kennt die Jungs mit den Bobby Cars. Und sie waren auch dort am Start und haben sehr viel Freude gemacht.
Team Otter, oder?
Genau, so hießen sie.
Das war sehr lustig. Es sind mehrere mobile unterwegs gewesen. Ich hab, glaub ich, nur einen Rennen gesehen. Und es gab so eine kleine Rampe, wo sich die meisten dann doch getraut haben, drüber zu hüpfen in dem Racing-Track. Ja, also genau, poste mal ein Video davon. Das war sehr unterhaltsam auf jeden Fall als außenstehende Person und wahrscheinlich auch als Mitfahrer. Wobei bei den meisten war die Federung wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen...
Ja, es war einfach so ein lustiger, dynamisch aufgebauter Race-Track mit Heuballen. Und dann sind die da einfach mit ihr, so sechs, sieben, acht Teams waren das irgendwie, sind mit ihren selbstgebauten Elektrokarren da rumgeflitzt. Und es war großes Hallo, wie Lurio sagen würde. Und das war schon mal sehr cool. Dann gab es überhaupt sehr viele Installationen, auch diese ganze Party-Installation da mit diesen Containern, Laser-Show, war alles sehr englisch hervorragend. Und die DJs, also mit dem Techno, das können die ja auch richtig gut. Das war wirklich gut. Das war wirklich, wirklich, wirklich richtig, richtig gut.
Zu dem Ding muss man noch dazu sagen, wir haben relativ nah daneben gekämpft, was eigentlich kein Thema war. Aber wir haben eine Sache immer mitbekommen. Und das waren diese nervigen Party-Tröten. Wir haben bis zum letzten Tag uns gedacht, Alter, habt ihr eine an der Macke, warum? Ach so, diese Hupe, dieses Horn. Ja, Horn, genau. Und wir dachten halt bis zum letzten Tag, dass halt die DJs so ein Nulltaktgefühl haben und das irgendwie random einsetzen. Bis wir dann rausgefunden haben, ne, das Ding war open for public und jeder konnte da an dieser Tröte herumtröten. Auf jeden Fall auch mit sehr viel Propangas diese Tröte. Also da war glaube ich die Tröte plus diese Feuer-Propangas-Installation, wo es dann auch schnell sehr warm wurde.
Und das war alles Teil der Kunstinstallation?
Genau, das war alles Teil der Kunstinstallation. Die Idee war auch sehr schön, mit den Schiffscontainern das zu bauen und ne Menge Laser da rein zu hämmern. Also Laser hatten sie viele.
Sie hatten viele Laser und sie hatten da überhaupt viel Kram. Und das war irgendwie alles ganz geil. Also EMF Camp ist auf jeden Fall heißer Tipp. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es in zwei Jahren am selben Ort wieder stattfinden wird. Und ich hoffe auch, dass sie dann die Ticketzahl deutlich erhöhen werden, weil da ist eine Menge Platz und da kann man sich ausdehnen. Ich verstehe, warum sie das erstmal ein bisschen begrenzt haben, aber da geht auf jeden Fall noch was. Ja, so viel zum EMF Camp. Ich lad mal dieses RACE-Video hoch. Das wird aber noch eine Sekunde dauern.
Das heißt, dann können wir ja schon mal übergehen, damit die User nicht so ungeduldig mit den Füßen scharren zur iOS Keynote.
Vielleicht noch meine tolle Wohnwagen-Camping-Entdeckung dieses Jahr. Als war er mit meinem Wohnwagen da. Das war für mich echt eine Revelation, wie man so schön sagt.
Akkuschrauber mitnehmen.
Allein schon um die Stützen dieses Wohnwagens hoch und runter zu fahren, mit einem Akkuschrauber, mit so einer langen Stange mit einer Nuss dran.
Nur nicht zu schnell, damit das nicht unten bricht. Du hast dir doch was kaputt gemacht.
Das hatte damit nichts zu tun. Das war nur so eine komische Platte, die unten dran war, weil sie sich irgendwo verhakt hat. Aber was wirklich der Knaller ist, sind Tellerschrauben. Tellerschrauben, also ich hab mir neulich erst starke Heringe gekauft, um irgendwie so diese Vordachplaner aufzubauen. Das brauch ich alles gar nicht mehr. Mein Leben ist jetzt komplett, denn es gibt Tellerschrauben. Und Tellerschrauben sind einfach lange Schrauben mit starken Gewindern. Also eigentlich Holzschrauben. Und davon hab ich mir einfach mal ein paar geholt. Und siehe da, die kann man dann nämlich auch wunderbar im Boden reinschrauben mit dem Akkuschrauber. Und das ist es irgendwie. Das ist echt der Hit, weil das geht schnell rein, das geht schnell wieder raus. Und mehr will man nicht mehr in seinem Leben. Ich poste mal, wie ich die Schrauben nicht mehr gekauft hab, das ist wirklich der Brüller. Tellerschrauben. Vielen Dank an den Björn an dieser Stelle, der mir diesen Tipp gegeben hat. Das ist einfach der Hit.
Dank Björn musste niemand über die Struppen oder über die Heringe schrauben.
Ja, weil die Schrauben sich ja auch ein bisschen in den Boden rein, da steht dann nichts mehr hoch. Und so schnell hast du ein Zelt nie wieder auf- und wieder abgebaut, wie damit.
Dann vielleicht noch kurz Danke für die Hörer, die uns angesprochen haben. Also, ich wurde auf jeden Fall ein oder zwei Mal angesprochen. Auch gefreut irgendwie Hörer aus England kennenzulernen.
Ach, die in England wohnen?
Das war sehr lustig.
Hallo Hörer in England.
Hallo Hörer in England. Das war niedlich bei euch.
Ja, ich fand's auch nice. So, wollen wir über Apple reden?
Na dann, auf geht's. Wir sind immerhin schon bei Apple, was Roddy da macht.
Ich bin gerade bei den neuen Animojis. Also irgendwie wurde jetzt gerade der Golden Master für die Entwickler freigegeben. Also habe ich jetzt mal iOS 12 installiert und klicke hier durch die Animoji. Und eins der großen neuen Features der Animoji ist ja, dass sie eine Zunge haben.
Ja.
Und der Totenkopf hat auch eine Zunge. Ja, aber ich meine, es ist ein Totenkopf. Der hat auch keine Augen. Wo sollen da eine Zunge herkommen?
Odi, kurze Information für dich. Das ist alles nur Spaß. Ach so. Das ist gar nicht echt.
Oh Mann.
Also ich benutze ja iOS 12 auch schon seit längerem. Also die Public Beta. Ist die jetzt auch schon wieder aktualisiert worden. Und muss sagen, das macht Spaß. Also das ist schon cool.
Die hat aber eine kleinere Zunge.
Na ja, gibt eine neue Version, die finale Version. Also jeder, der Public Beta hat, der kriegt jetzt das iOS 12 schon. Wann soll das offiziell released werden?
Eine Woche oder zwei, hatten sie doch vorhin gesagt.
Ja, ich hab's mich nur nicht gemerkt.
Mitte September, glaube ich. Und wenn ihr ja gerade irgendwas schmatzen gehört habt, das war nicht ich, die schon wieder irgendetwas gegessen hat. Das ist Roddy, der hier die ganzen Animojis ausprobiert.
Ja, ich zeige meinem Telefon die ganze Zeit die Zunge. Damit hier eine niedliche Katze die Zunge rausstreckt.
Ist schön.
Ja, dabei sind andere Funktionen viel wichtiger.
Der Roboter hat auch eine Zunge. Geil.
Lass uns mal über diese Keynote sprechen. Die war nämlich gerade, wie wir schon erwähnt haben. Und ich muss sagen, ich hab mich ein bisschen gewundert. Ich finde, ihr habt ja, ihr habt euch ein bisschen, ihr habt so ein bisschen den Glauben verloren, hab ich so den Eindruck, ne? Ihr holt euch dem Apple ja überhaupt gar nicht mehr richtig.
Man muss dazu sagen, ich glaub, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich mir das wirklich in voller Gänze gegeben hab.
Wirklich?
Nö, das hab ich bisher immer.
Du hattest ja echt ganz schön gutes Sitzfleisch.
Ja, ich hab die letzten Male schon Skip, Skip, Skip gemacht. Ich hab die immer nach hinein geschaut, damit ich skippen kann.
Naja, also Revolutionary und The Best That We Ever Did kamen jetzt irgendwie drei- oder viermal in Folge und es wird ein bisschen alt langsam.
Na, das haben sie schon immer gemacht.
Naja, aber ich hab so das Gefühl, so die letzten drei Keynotes oder vier wollten sie immer den Anbruch einer neuen Zeit verkünden und gut zum iPhone X war das auch halbwegs gerechtfertigt.
Ja, total gerechtfertigt meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, da war das gerechtfertigt. Aber jetzt haben sie es diesmal wieder und das klang dann doch ein bisschen hohl.
Ich find's wieder gerechtfertigt.
Na gut, dann geht's los.
Was ich mal kurz, weil alle schon sagten, hier so irgendwie was von den Rumors erwartbar war, ich hab mir explizit nichts auf Mac-Rumors vorher angeschaut, damit ich so ein Überraschungserlebnis habe.
Ah, und hattest du das? Nee. Warum? Weil du damit gerechnet hast?
Nee, weil ich, also für mich, was ich wirklich schade finde, ist, dass die Telefone halt so groß jetzt wirklich sind. Also ich find, egal welches, hat halt schon dann relativ groß, also ist relativ groß.
Genau, das würde ich nämlich jetzt auch vorschlagen. Fangen wir doch mal vorne an. So, abgesehen von diesem ganzen Filmkram am Anfang, ich glaub, das müssen wir jetzt irgendwie nicht.
Das Intro-Film, ich fand das super.
War ganz lustig, aber am Ende auch nicht sehr viel mehr als das. Und dann wurden halt so diese üblichen Zahlen verkündet, wie viele tolle Geräte es doch schon gibt und ihre Apple Stores und wie hübsch die doch alle sind und Pipa Bo und kein Interesse jetzt. Dann kam die Apple Watch, damit haben sie irgendwie angefangen und relativ schnell klargemacht, dass sie jetzt hier mal wieder einen großen Wurf meinen geleistet zu haben. Und dem kann man sich, glaube ich, auch anschließen. Jetzt gibt es natürlich Leute, die können mit der Apple Watch überhaupt nichts anfangen. Da gehöre ich ja nicht dazu.
Ja, die haben keine, deswegen.
Die haben keinen Use Case dafür.
Ja, der Use Case, der kommt relativ schnell. Man merkt, es gibt den Use Case. Zum Beispiel benutze ich extrem oft den Timer. Zumindest, also vor allen Dingen, damit der Tee nicht zu lange zieht. Ja, also irgendwie, das ist halt einmal auf die Uhr tappen, dann ist der Timer auf drei Minuten. Und wenn der Prinz am Handgelenk rappelt, und vor allen Dingen, das muss ich auch extra abstellen. Das ist so was, das nervt andere nicht, aber mich. Also merke ich das, dass das jetzt soweit ist, dass ich dann den Tee rausnehme. Und seitdem habe ich nie wieder lauwarmen Tee, der eine Viertelstunde gezogen hat.
Ja, also...
Das ist jetzt dein News-Case. Das ist dein News-Case.
Das hätte der Chief Apple-Watch-Marketing-Officer auch nicht besser an dem Mann oder die Frau gingen können.
Der hätte mal mit mir gesprochen.
Ja, also ich meine, so eine Apple Watch ist halt noch näher dran als so ein Telefon. Das muss man schon mal sagen. Das ist halt immer da. Und manche Sachen sind noch besser, wenn sie auch immer da sind. Das Telefon ist schon sehr viel näher an einen herangerückt, als es die Rechner, die Laptops vorher auch getan haben. Und die Uhr ist halt noch mal näher dran. Und die Anwendungen, die davon profitieren, haben es natürlich besser, wenn sie auf der Watch ordentlich laufen.
Ich möchte das K-Wort jetzt gar nicht in den Mund geben.
Aber bleiben wir nochmal ganz kurz bei den Features. Also, es gibt eine neue Apple Watch. Die Series 4. Das ist das erste, wirklich neue Design. Bisher waren die anderen alle in demselben Formfaktor. Jetzt gibt es einen neuen Formfaktor. Wie der so genau ist, ist irgendwie noch nicht so ganz klar. Aber es macht den Eindruck, als ob es minimal breiter geworden ist.
Nee, es ist höher geworden. Also, höher. Also, die ist jetzt nicht mehr quadratisch. Also gut, die andere war auch nicht so richtig quadratisch. Aber die ist jetzt deutlich rechteckig und nicht mehr so quadratisch. Wenn man, wenn man auf, wenn man im Apple Store guckt, irgendwo hatte ich das hier, Apple Watch, dann sieht man das relativ gut. Also hier Höhe 44, Breite 38, beziehungsweise Höhe 40 und Breite 34.
Höhe, also mit Höhe, das hätte ich ja jetzt eher Länge genannt. Also Höhe ist für mich, wie dick das Ding ist.
Das ist für mich die Dicke.
Was ist denn die Dicke? Ist das Ding jetzt dünner?
10,7 Millimeter, weiß ich nicht, wie viel die vorher war. Aber sie haben behauptet, sie wäre jetzt nicht mehr ganz so dick.
Sieht nicht mehr so dick aus auf den Fotos, aber ich hab jetzt die Zahlen ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz im Kopf.
Ja, wir messen mal nach.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht schiebeleere raus.
Wie genau ist denn dein Finger?
Ziemlich.
Letty misst jetzt die Uhr mit ihrem Finger, die hat da nämlich so...
Sollen wir mal was mitgebracht? Zentimeter auf jeden Fall.
Hat er so Zentimeter auf jeden Fall. Ja gut, aber die neue ist ja auch 10,7 Millimeter. Das ist, wenn ich mich nicht verrechnet hab, auch über einen Zentimeter. Also sie haben es behauptet, sie wäre jetzt dünner. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt einfach so.
Was meinst du, sie wäre einen satten Millimeter dünner oder was? Ja, also das ist wirklich minimal. 10,7 zu 11,4, also 0,7 Millimeter.
Oh ja, das haut's natürlich total raus. 0,7 Millimeter, Alter.
So 5 Prozent sind das schon. Sie ist ja auch wurschtig. Also sie ist auf jeden Fall größer. Und also vorher hat sie so ein 38 Millimeter Gehäuse, jetzt 40. Ich meine, so ein bisschen rechteckig war die auch vorher schon. Das ist jetzt gar nichts.
Ja, ja, war sie. Aber es fällt bei der stärker auf.
Aber der Bildschirm, die Real genutzte Fläche für den Bildschirm ist viel größer. Und sie haben halt so Curved Edges.
Also das Ding ist nicht ein viereckiger Screen, sondern es ist in die Edges hineingescreened.
Gab es ja vor ein paar Tagen auch irgendwie so ein Posting, dass sie sich da extra nochmal ein Patent haben geben lassen, wie man so Hardware-Antialiasing macht für runde Bildschirme. Jetzt wissen wir warum.
Die Samsung-Jünger sagen, das gab es doch vorher schon mal.
Was gab es vorher schon?
Curved-Bildschirme.
Es gab halt runde Dinger, so Kreisrundeuhren.
Näher dieses Samsung Edge, wo das Bild, wo der Screen ja auch... Auch da in die Rundung von dem Edge reingeht.
Nein, hier geht es ja nicht darum, dass es nach unten geht, sondern dass einfach nur die Ecke rund ist.
Ja, so wie beim iPhone X und nachfolgende Geräte.
Anyway, das Ding hat neue Sensoren. Unter anderem einen angeblich besser funktionierenden Accelerometer und Gyroskop, mit dem sie jetzt feststellen können, dass du gerade die Leiter runtergefallen bist. Und dann schlägst du zwar immer noch auf, also sie entfalten keinen Rettungsfallschirm oder so, womit ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerechnet hätte. Aber sie können irgendwie rausfinden, ob man fällt, ob man irgendwie hinfällt oder ausrutscht oder so was. Und wenn du dann auf dem Boden landest, dann kriegst du gleich Angeboten, dass du beim Arzt anrufst oder bei der Rettung.
Nicht ein Genius-Termin im Apple Store machst für eine neue Uhr?
Das passiert, das kommt wahrscheinlich nur bei dir.
Nee, nee, das könnte sein, ja.
Der Termin wird automatisch mit dem Fall vereinbart.
Sehr cool finde ich auch die anderen kleinen Änderungen, nämlich diese Digital Crown ist jetzt wohl anders gebaut und hat jetzt haptisches Feedback. Das bedeutet wahrscheinlich so viel, dass wenn du durch Listen durchgehst, dass du dieses Klack-klack-klack-klack-klack auf einmal im Finger hast und das ist natürlich super.
Ich frage mich, ob das ein festes Raster ist, was da klickert oder ob sie tatsächlich on-demand haptisch Feedback machen.
Ja, das ist wieder so ein... Sie haben ja eh dieses... Die Haptik ist doch eh schon in der Uhr drin. Die benutzen das jetzt bloß noch bei dem Rad. Inwiefern das eine Eigenschaft ist, das ist wahrscheinlich keine Eigenschaft des Rads, das ist einfach nur, dass sie das in die Software mit eingebaut haben. Unter Umständen kriegen wir das auch noch bei der alten Uhr, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Lautsprecher ist angeblich lauter und Radiowaves gehen jetzt besser nach unten durch deinen Körper hindurch, sodass vielleicht diese LTE-Verbindungsprobleme weggehen, die wohl die Leute, die eine Uhr mit LTE haben, beobachtet haben. Ich hab sowas nicht, keine Ahnung, ob das realistisch ist. Und ich glaub das große Ding ist wirklich dieser neue Herzsensor, wo sie halt einerseits jetzt irgendwie meinen rauszufinden, wenn du, wie in...
Kammer flimmern?
Kammer flimmern, also diese High Heart Rate Notification, die sie hatten, die war ja schon im Prinzip ein Hinweis da drauf. Und das haben sie jetzt nochmal ausgebaut und analysieren den Herzrhythmus und entsprechende Störungen. Und wenn man auch zu niedrigen Herzschlag hat, all diese ganzen Dinge. Und der Oberbruder ist natürlich, dass du mit dem Teil jetzt ein EKG machen kannst. Das ist irgendwie echt fit.
Da frage ich mich, ob man die Uhr am linken Arm vertragen muss.
Das ist wirklich eine gute Frage.
Oder ob das auch... Ja, weil... Sie hatten es so gezeigt. Also ich hab sie auf dem rechten Arm. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht messen die ja sowieso nur die Spannung zwischen den Armen, dann wär's egal.
So hab ich das verstanden. Du machst, um das EKG zu machen, musst du den Finger an die Crown, damit du da einen elektrischen Kontakt herstellst.
Genau, dann messen sie einmal am Arm und einmal an der Crown die andere Hand. Ja, wahrscheinlich reicht's auch. Ist wahrscheinlich egal, auf welcher Seite.
Das würde mich jetzt sehr wundern.
Weil du bei einem klassischen EKG, die ja asymmetrisch klebst, die Dinge.
Ja, mir ist ein bisschen ein Rätsel, wie das technisch genau funktioniert, aber es schien sich da ja sehr sicher zu sein, dass das irgendwie funktioniert. Auf jeden Fall kann man das halt anstoßen. Man kann so ein EKG machen und kriegt dann irgendwie auch gleich ein fertiges PDF zum Ausdrucken, was man an seinem Arzt auf den Tisch legen kann. Und dann sagen, guck mal, so sieht's aus. Ich hab mal ein EKG gemacht.
Ich hab mal ein EKG geschrieben.
Bei euch kriegt man ja keinen Termin. Tralala.
Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen noch auf einen Blutdrucksensor gehofft, aber das ist wahrscheinlich dann doch zu viel vielleicht.
Ja, das könnte schwierig werden.
Thala, die vor einigen Sendungen ja hier mal bei uns zu Gast war, hat mir vorhin auch noch einen Link geschickt, der ist von 2016 sogar das bereits schon andere Hersteller. Also es gab einen anderen Hersteller, der auch das EKG hat. Also es ist nicht Apple als erstes, wie sie es gerade verkauft haben.
An der Uhr?
An einem Armband.
Die werden schon eine Formulierung gefunden haben, in der sie Recht haben. Die Frage ist nur, welches Detail anders ist.
Wahrscheinlich der erste Smartwatch mit.
Wahrscheinlich. Und im Artikel ist auch noch mal beschrieben, wie weit das, glaube ich, voneinander entfernt sein muss, sodass du halt trotz alledem ein gutes Ergebnis hast, weil Ärzte sagen halt so, man kann das heranziehen. Das ist, weil wir uns ja vorhin gefragt haben, wie akkurat am Handgelenk etwas gemessen ist, im Vergleich zu, du setzt es direkt an der Stelle auf, wo das Herz ist. Und da sagt man halt, dass es nicht so ein krasser Unterschied ist. Also man kann das immer noch auswerten.
Also ich meine, wenn sie wirklich... Ja, bist du richtig verstanden, dass sie in den USA auch schon die Zertifizierung haben?
Die haben in den USA die FDA, heißt das, glaube ich.
Ja, sie haben nicht gesagt genau, was für eine Zertifizierung das ist. Also...
Das ist auf jeden Fall, FDA ist für Arzneimittel zuständig.
Interessanterweise scheinen sie das Feature tatsächlich auch nur dort auszurollen, wo sie auch eine Zertifizierung haben. Zumindest klang das für mich so.
So habe ich das auch verstanden. Das heißt, das ist ein Feature, was wir hier erstmal nicht bekommen werden.
Warum ist mir jetzt unklar?
Na, weil sie da einfach als erstes jetzt durchmarschiert sind, weil sie das am besten...
Ja, aber warum bieten sie das nicht an, obwohl sie keine... Also, was hindert sie daran, das Feature trotzdem auszurollen, auch wenn es nicht zertifiziert ist?
Dass alle Leute dann sagen werden, das wäre ja nicht zertifiziert, und das ist alles Quatsch.
Das kann sein, dass die Studien fehlen. Ich habe im Übrigen vor einiger Zeit mal mit jemandem sich zufällig geredet, der Studiendaten verwaltet, unter anderem von der Apple Watch mit.
Kann den Taler am nächsten Mal kommen und uns das mal aus ihrer Perspektive...
Ich glaube, die kleine Taler liegt schon im Bett. Das werde ich sie morgen fragen, ich denke schon. Sie wäre ja auch für das iPhone nochmal...
Also Taler, wenn du das hörst...
Bist du schon verpflichtet. Genau.
So, dann gibt es das Ganze irgendwie in... Silber und Gold und Space Gray. Und irgendwie auch noch in der Stahl-Variante, in Polished, in Black und Gold.
Ja, Aluminium und Stahl, ne?
Aluminium und Stahl, aber Stahl jetzt auch in Gold. Was auch immer das für ein Gold ist. Nur so ein Goldfinish. Ob das richtiges Gold ist, weiß ich nicht, ja.
Sie haben es Goldfinish genannt, was ich so interpretiert würde, dass es nur die Farbe ist, aber dass da nicht unbedingt Gold drin ist.
Nicht vergoldet.
Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Wobei, wenn sie vergolden würden, wäre jetzt auch nicht so viel Gold drauf, oder?
Ich kenne mich nicht aus.
Ich auch nicht. Kostet auf jeden Fall 399 Dollar. Also ich weiß nicht, die deutschen Preise.
429, 529.
USA Preise sind ja auch immer ohne Mehrwertsteuer und so. Und wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, wird die LTE-Variante in Deutschland dann nicht nur von Telekom, sondern auch von Vodafone unterstützt. Sehr schön. Und die Series 3, die man auch noch kaufen kann, wenn man will, die gibt es dann schon für 279 Dollar. Und hierfür, was ich nicht trauende, dann wahrscheinlich oder sowas. Ja, also kann ja sein, dass Leute die Uhr doof finden, aber ich finde das Ding jetzt erstmal ganz interessant. Größerer Bildschirm ist auf jeden Fall ein Plus. Ein bisschen flacher ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Plus. Wie sich das so niederschlägt, muss man mal gucken. Wenn es dünner ist und breiter, wirkt es ja auf jeden Fall dünner.
Wie gesagt, 0,7 Millimeter.
Die macht auf jeden Fall ein schlankes Handgelände.
Aber sie ist ja auch breiter. Also im Verhältnis.
Habt ihr beide die große?
Ja, also ich hab die große.
Ich auch. Ich bin ja auch ein Dude. Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wo ist meine Uhr, die ich im Hals trage?
Wo ist unser White Russian hier?
Genau, das wäre doch vielleicht überhaupt das Ding. Irgendwie, wenn ich dann die neue Watch habe, dann hänge ich mir die alte einfach so fleffmäßig um den Hals.
Als Badge.
Die ist groß geworden als Badge, genau.
Ich glaube, cool wäre es dir nur, wenn du dir so ein iPad um den Hals hängen würdest. Um richtig cool zu sein, aber das A4 iPad, also hier das große.
Das Pro.
Das Pro, genau.
Das ist auch nicht dir.
Einfach alte iPads raushauen, genau.
Also ich überlege ja das erste Mal in der Existenz dieser Uhr, ob ich mir die vielleicht doch auch mal kaufen sollte. Denn ich habe mein Lieblingsaccessoire verloren kürzlich von Apple. Ein Produkt, das es nicht mehr käuflich zu erwerben gibt. Und wenn dann nur zum Neupreis, obwohl das Gerät End of Life ist. Ja, glücklicherweise haben mir jetzt schon ein, zwei Hörer angeboten, ihre nicht mehr genutzten Shuffle zu überlassen. Kommen vielleicht in der Metaebene an, unter anderem. Und sie werden auch eingesetzt werden, weil ich nicht eingesehen habe, für dieses Gerät nochmal 170 Euro zu bezahlen. Wie es manche Händler immer noch gerne hätten. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ist denn also, ne, also die Uhr, also ich hab ja sowieso schon überlegt, so Smartwatch wäre jetzt auch für das Segelthema irgendwie in Teilen interessant zum Sport. Hätte ich auch gerne durchaus so ein paar Tracking-Daten mit dem iPhone, ist es ja doch alles ein bisschen mühsam, das von Hand einzugeben und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt dachte ich mir, okay, wenn ich dann diese Uhr hätte, dann könnte ich ja da auch meine Musik drauf löten und dann müsste ich halt mal Bluetooth-Kopfhörer mir noch irgendwann zulegen. Und dann wäre das ja fast so Shuffle-Formfaktor und so weiter mit noch mehr Features. Und wenn es sogar jetzt auch noch LTE hat, dann kann ich ja sogar Apple Music streamen. Und alles, was ich sonst so habe. Insofern denke ich jetzt zumindest mal ernsthaft darüber nach. Jetzt dadurch, dass die Hörer, also ich habe auf Twitter gefragt, ob jemand noch iPod-Shuffles hat, die er nicht mehr braucht. Und da haben sich dann irgendwie gleich drei gemeldet. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, also die... Reicht erst mal. Na, die direkte musikalische Zukunft. Weil gerade beim Sport benutze ich halt den Shuffle sehr gerne. Oder auf so Reisen, wo ich nicht irgendwie großes Kopfhörer- und Mediatheksgedöns an mir haben will, sondern einfach nur diesen kleinen Clip so in ihr Kopfhörer pengen.
Ja, vor allem auch wenn du... Ich hab das, gerade wenn du in Südamerika unterwegs bist, so in einem Bus reisen halt, standardmäßig an mir dran das Ding ein. Weil dann musst du halt auch nicht mit deinem Telefon rumhanteln. Gut, mit meiner Möhre... Das klauen sie eh nicht.
Ja, ich bin ja Kabelfreund, das weiß der.
Naja, also den Zahn hab ich mir jetzt echt gezogen. Also wenn man erstmal Bluetooth-Headphone-Land angekommen ist, so richtig, dann schaut man Kabel nur noch mit dem Arsch an.
Ich hatte kürzlich Bluetooth-Kopfhörer auf und die hatten irgendwie so ein, weiß ich nicht, immer wenn Ruhe war, haben die so...
Musst ihr welche von Apple kaufen oder von Bose?
Ja, also ich brauch halt welche, die so richtig so rein... Weil hatten wir ja schon ein paar Mal in der Freak Show, dass diese Apple-Normalform bei mir halt rausfliegt und wenn ich dann so auf dem Laufband gerade am Abziehen bin, dann...
Ja, das wär mir auch ein zu teures Experiment.
Ja, wenn die dann in unterm Laufband vielleicht am besten noch egalerweise reinfallen. Genau, also... Ja, also ich hab jetzt gerade schon mal geklickt, auf welchen Preis man sich denn da so einstellen müsste. Vielleicht in einer der zukünftigen Folgen.
Kannst du ja auch diese Beats, diese Sportbeats irgendwie...
Ja, ich müsste da mal recherchieren. Vielleicht haben ja da irgendwelche Leute Erfahrungen, welche in ihr Kopfhörer Bomben sicher beim Sport halten.
Die kosten das auch in ihr, die kosten nur irgendwie den Honi und das Bluetooth und fertig.
Und dann würde mich ja noch interessieren, ob es, unter den Hörern gibt es ja auf jeden Fall auch Segelinteressierte, ob es da denn auch irgendwelche Apps gibt, die besonders irgendwie segelorientierte Features haben und so. Navigation zum Beispiel und so. Das würde mich sehr interessieren, weil ich habe ein bisschen gegoogelt und bisher nur Müll gefunden. Und das wäre ein weiterer Kaufanreiz für eine Smartwatch. Denn die ganzen anderen Smartwatches, die es gibt, die so für Outdoor und auch Wassersport gemacht sind, die haben einfach so grauenvolle Interfaces, Batterylives, Applikationen, also einfach alles schlecht.
Wobei ich da jetzt sagen muss, Apple hat ja gesagt, so sechs Stunden Aktivität unterstützen sie. Und das ist halt echt wenig.
Das ist bei den anderen aber auch teilweise doch schlechter.
Sechs Stunden Herz aufzeichnen und GPS ist schon...
Was willst du denn, sechs Stunden Sport machen am Stück?
Ich nutze das Ding ja zum Wandern zum Beispiel auch. Ich habe zum Wandern und für Fahrradtouren meine Polaruhr mit Herzfrequenzmesser dabei. Also zum Wandern nehme ich jetzt manchmal den Herzfrequenzmesser nicht mehr mit, weil das mir nicht so wichtiger ist.
Du misst die Uhr ja immer regelmäßig.
Ja, aber nicht so regelmäßig, während du sie aufspornest.
Ja, aber beim Wandern brauchst du nicht...
Beim Wandern willst du aber deine Strecke aufzeichnen. Und du bist halt in der Regel nicht sechs Stunden unterwegs, sondern teilweise eher länger. Also wenn du längere Strecken läufst.
Und auch für so einen langen Segelturnen wäre das auch durchaus interessant. Den ganzen Track, den Speed, alle Stats, so Kurse etc. Alles schön immer mit aufzuzeichnen. Und da gibt es halt auch so ein, zwei Uhren, aber dann ist halt genau auch so diese Aktiv-Tracking-Zeit...
Warte mal, den Track, den du mit deinem Segelboot fährst, dann macht doch dein Telefon...
Ja, aber ich hätte es halt auch gerne so...
Das Telefon, das musst du ja nicht an... Ich meine, das kannst du ja irgendwo an Strom hängen und aufzeichnen lassen. Also das ist ja keine Körperfunktion, die du da aufzeichnest.
Das kommt halt noch mit hinzu vielleicht, aber ich hätte es halt einfach... Wäre ja auch nicht schlecht, wenn das einfach alles mit der Uhr geht, ohne Telefon. Und das Telefon da ganz entspannt...
Was ich jetzt halt einige Male gemacht habe, ist, wenn ich an die Grenze von meiner Uhr gekommen bin, dadurch, dass ich halt mir jetzt prinzipiell um die Herzfrequenz zum Beispiel beim Fahrradfahren geht, einfach fix noch die Uhr an die Powerbank, die eh dabei ist, angeschlossen und mir kurz an den Lenker geschnackt.
Aber die Uhr kann man ja nur induktionsladen. Das heißt, man muss den Induktionsdödel, den Battery Pack und dann irgendwo in Ort legen. Also ich meine, das Battery Life damit komme ich noch am ehesten zurecht wahrscheinlich.
Sie lädt aber relativ schnell auf. Also das ist irgendwie echt strange. Du kannst sie irgendwie...
Eine halbe Stunde oder?
Also wenn es wirklich runter ist, kannst du sie irgendwie in einer Viertelstunde wieder auf 50% laden.
Okay, das ist wirklich gut.
Aber hier zu dem Punkt, dass wir so ein bisschen underwhelmed waren, also ich gehe so richtig aus dem Leim bei, wenn die so Sachen ankündigen, die so mehr Richtung Trikorder gehen noch. Ich will das komplette Sensorpaket in diesen Devices haben, irgendwie so all features on, zum Beispiel dieses, dieses Kamera-Feature, wo sie jetzt so toll irgendwie... Ach so, wir sind jetzt noch bei der Uhr, ne?
Wir sind bei der Uhr und wir planen.
Wir sind bei der Uhr.
Funkdisziplin, Funkdisziplin. Also ich bin auf jeden Fall... Ich find das Ding sieht gut aus. Ich guck mal, was man da so jetzt investieren müsste.
Also ich werd mir glaub ich auf jeden Fall eine shoppen, weil meine ist halt immer noch die originale und das Teil, das ist halt so langsam, das geht mir auf den Sack.
Ja, also das hier ist nur...
Die neuste WatchOS-Version krieg ich auf die Uhr nicht mehr drauf und damit ist es halt irgendwie klar, da sitzt eine neue.
Hast du jetzt wirklich noch eine Null? Du hast doch irgendwie x-mal eine Neue bekommen. Haben sie da nicht mittlerweile eine Eins gegeben?
Also gut, ich mein, wenn jetzt, ich kann dann...
Bist du sicher?
Gleich noch mal versuchen an goldenen Höhen. Nö, da steht bestimmt, da steht bestimmt nicht Serious 1 drauf.
Muss man deine Seriennummer bei everything, everymac.com eingeben?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist immer noch die Originale. Also, ja, keine Ahnung. Also wenn man so wirklich durch die Features durchguckt, sind interessante Titbits drin. Titbits, Titbits, 16 Gigabyte Kapazität finde ich irgendwie so auf der Uhr. Macht Sinn.
Mein Alphard Shuffle hat zwei gehabt.
GPS, GLONASS, Galileo und QZSS. Haben wir da mal drüber geredet? Das ist ein chinesisches System oder was ist QZSS?
Quasi Zenit Satelliten System.
Also man kriegt da wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall einen Fix mit.
Ja, machen die ja alle jetzt Galileo und so weiter.
Aber vieles von dem war auch in der Series 3 drin. Der barometrische Höhenmesser war der auch schon in der 3?
Ja, die haben alles eigentlich außer einen echten Kompass. Also echt.
Ja, die neue Uhr ist auf 64-Bit Dual-Core. Angeblich noch mal doppelt so schnell, nachdem die 3 schon doppelt so schnell waren und die 2 doppelt so schnell waren.
Bei der Null sind sie aber auch relativ langsam eingestiegen.
Ja, aber das Ding wird langsam fix. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir jedes Mal eine Verdopplung gehabt. Das heißt, Series 2 war doppelt so schnell, 3 also achtmal so schnell. Oh ja, darf auch ich mich dran stellen? Der Akku hält halt mega lang, das ist schon irgendwie nice. Und größerer Bildschirm macht sich auf jeden Fall gut. Die alte Uhr wird auf jeden Fall alt aussehen dagegen.
Lauterer Lautsprecher ist wahrscheinlich dann, kann man damit das Ding auch mal benutzen, mit Lautsprecher.
Hast du eine mit SIM?
Was mir übrigens jetzt gerade erst auffällt, wenn ich so hier rechts die große Taste drücke und dann durch die letzten Apps durchscrolle, mach mal.
Was ist dann?
Na ja, da fällt mir ein, dass der Screenshot, der dann angezeigt wird von den Apps, schon immer abgerundete Ecken hatte.
Das fällt dir jetzt auf?
Das fällt mir jetzt gerade erst auf.
Ja, war schon immer so.
Richtig.
Ja, aber das ist sozusagen so, wie es dann...
Ja, nun.
Tim, hast du eine mit GSM?
Weil ich weder Telekom-Kunde war zu dem Zeitpunkt und jetzt vielleicht zwar Werder, aber...
Ich frage mich, ob das sinnvoll ist....
auch die Preise, wie Jens Sals von Gut und Böse.
Ich frage mich, ob das sinnvoll ist.
Also es ist vielleicht dann sinnvoll, wenn man Apple Music macht, und jetzt mit dem Podcast-Feature von WatcherOS 5 wird das natürlich interessant. Und man muss jetzt mal gucken, die anderen App-Entwickler Overcast wird eine Podcast-Funktionalität haben, etc. Wenn das mit dem Syncing und so weiter oder runterladen, dann muss man noch mal gucken, wie das genau funktioniert. Aber wenn das alles ordentlich funktioniert, dann kann man ja tatsächlich Sport machen, ohne das Telefon dabei zu haben. Und du kannst noch angerufen werden, und du hast GPS-Tracking und du hast...
GPS-Tracking hast du auch mit der ohne Cellular. Laut den Daten hat der nämlich auch GPS-Tracking.
Ja klar, aber du brauchst das Telefon nicht mehr, wenn du all diese Dinge haben willst. Das war ja bisher nicht möglich.
Also Daten.
Ja, also wenn ich laufe, dann will ich halt, dass meine Router aufgezeichnet wird, dass mein Herz aufgezeichnet wird, und ich will Podcasts hören. So, und das ging halt...
Die ersten zwei Sachen gehen halt mit der ohne Cellular.
Genau, so und Leute, die halt gerne irgendwie Musik hören beim Laufen, was ich ja persönlich nicht nachvollziehen kann, die können halt jetzt irgendwie das machen. Deswegen hat das Ding auch so viel RAM, so viel Speicher, so viel SSD drauf, damit sie da schön viel zwischenbuffern können.
Aber man kann auch manuell Musik da drauf kopieren?
Ja, das ging schon immer.
Und warum war jetzt der Preis, du meinst den Providerpreis für Apple Watches SIM?
Ich glaube, die Telekom will dafür, dass die SIM auch auf dieser Uhr aktiv ist, pro Monat noch mal 10 Euro oder so sehen.
Wir nehmen doch auch für eine normale SIM, wenn du eine Multi-SIM hast, nichts zusätzliches, oder?
Erstens doch und zweitens nehmen sie halt hier noch mal besonders viel, was ich aber insbesondere bei dieser Uhr nicht verstehe. Weil sie ja erstens sowieso immer nur alternativ zum Telefon ist, also sie sind ja noch nicht mal gleichzeitig aktiv. Und ich meine, eine Uhr, ich bitte dich.
Telekomiker?
Fünf Euro sind das, okay. Na ja, also demnächst, schöneres Hinfallen mit Apple Watch. Man kann dann wahrscheinlich auch besser damit telefonieren, was durchaus ein Feature ist.
Lauteres andere Leute nerven.
Lauteres andere Leute nerven. Und ja, dann sehen wir demnächst, die coolen Kids durch die Straße ziehen, dann haben sie nicht mehr ihren Ghetto Blaster dabei, sondern kommt der Sound einfach von der Watch.
Und halten nicht mehr das Telefon wie so ein Stück Pizzapodyschnute, sondern...
Die Series 7 hat einen Zapfruf, ich sag's dir, durch den ganzen Körper durch.
Beziehungsweise kann man nicht so eine Bluetooth-Boombox auch an die Apple Watch perren?
Müssen doch gehen. Du strahlst das einfach direkt in den Körper rein, dann spürst du das einfach direkt.
Ja, aber die anderen ja nicht.
Und dann warte ich auf den Tag, an dem sie endlich diesen Elektroschocker einbauen, damit man durch die Straße gehen kann und jeden dieser Trottel elektroschocken kann.
Ach, du möchtest eine Taser-Option haben? Welche Trottel meinst du jetzt noch mal genau?
Die, die dir in der U-Bahn auf die Ketten gehen mit ihrem lauten Uzz, Uzz, Uzz.
Ey du, darf ich dich mal streicheln?
Muss nur ein Finger auf die Crown legen. Ja, genau, das mein ich ja zum Beispiel. So ein Laserdistanzmesser.
Gorgogadgetto Taser, ja. Den nehm ich.
Warum nicht? Ich will Trikorder.
Aber ich muss trotzdem noch mal sagen, ich finde den Start-Screen in all den Möglichkeiten, die man ihnen befüllen kann.
Welchen Start-Screen?
Das Watch-Face, genau.
Da gibt's ja mehrere.
Genau, und das aber in der vollsten Ausführung, was sie in der Keynote-Präsentation auch drin hatten.
Dieses Runde mit den Ecken.
Genau, das was, wenn du den Bestell-Wildschirm aufhast, irgendwie auch siehst. Ich glaube, wenn du auf der Startseite bist, Tim, hast du das auch auf der Apple Startseite. Und da ist mir halt aufgefallen, ihr habt ja gesagt, ja, das will man als Nutzer. Wie krass vollgeladen dieser Bildschirm für mich aussieht. Also für mich war Apple immer halt so vom Design her etwas sehr klares, aufgeräumtes. Und da, finde ich, ist es das erste Mal, dass ich mir denke, okay, packen wir alles auf diesen kleinen Space, der zur Verfügung ist, alles was man draufpacken kann. Also diese vier runden Teile.
Ich finde da nichts falsch dran. Weil erstens ist es ja hochgradig konfigurierbar. Das ist jetzt nur der Vollausbau. Das sind alles Complications. Die kannst du dann einzeln einstellen, was du da genau angezeigt haben möchtest. Und außerdem hat mir genau das immer gefehlt. Also ich wollte immer mehr Sachen haben, gleichzeitig. Und es gab kein Watchface, wo das irgendwie gepasst hat. Also der Bedarf entsteht schon schnell. Und wenn du es minimalistisch haben willst, gibt es da ja genug minimalistischen Kram.
Ja, vor allen Dingen. Ja, vor allen Dingen, du kannst halt relativ einfach die Watchfaces wechseln und kannst halt je nach Situation dann das Watchface... Was ist denn das hier? Laser Schwertkapzen.
Letty in der U-Bahn.
Ja, der Chat lenkt uns schon wieder ab. Das ist alles nicht gut. Diesmal ist der Chat schuld.
Nicht Bier.
Ja, okay, wenn man das alles noch zu haben will, ja, man kann es ändern, aber das fand ich interessant, dass sie mit so einem Bildschirm dann als erstes rausgehen, weil ich fand das mega abtörnd als ersten Eindruck.
Na ja gut, ich meine, mein Standard-Watch-Face hat jetzt irgendwie auch alles an, was so geht.
Okay, ich glaube, ich bin einfach zu minimalistisch.
Weil die Watch halt auch, es ist halt auch ein, na, Infotainment ist jetzt der falsche Ausdruck, also es ist halt ein Infoscreen, ein Personal Dashboard. Also es ist halt ein Infoscreen, wo du halt auch teilweise möglichst viele Informationen drauf haben willst. Also wenn ich nur zwei Zeige haben will, könnte ich mir auch eine normale Uhr umbinden. Die Laserschwertkatzen, die den Hund jagen.
Eine letzte Anmerkung noch zu diesem Kinoteil. Ich hab mich gewundert, warum dieser Jeff Williams das präsentiert hat. Und? Naja, der Typ ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist der COO.
Naja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht wollte es keine anderen machen oder...
Aber dann könntest du es ja auch genauso sagen, warum steht da die Marketing-Chefin dann zum Beispiel bei den Phones drauf. Also es ist ja dieselbe.
Na, weil es Marketing ist in dem Moment. Also das ist ganz auch der... Phil Schiller ist ja der Chef des Marketings, der hat schon immer das vorgestellt.
Ja, aber du kannst ja nicht immer nur dieselben Leute da stehen haben.
Es sind bei Apple immer die Leute, die dafür auch verantwortlich sind. Das ist eigentlich durchgehend so. Du hast nahezu ohne Ausnahme immer die Leute, die für den jeweiligen Bereich auch tatsächlich zuständig sind. Die präsentieren das. Und das hat mich bei dem Jeff Williams gewundert, weil der ist CEO. Wenn sich da jetzt nicht irgendwas geändert hat. Vorher war ja der Tim Cook der CEO. Und das ist quasi derjenige, der diesen ganzen, also Operating Officer heißt ja, diesen ganzen Laden am Laufen zu halten. Tim Cook hat seinerzeit diesen ganzen China Connection aufgebaut, diesen ganzen unfassbaren Workflow, diesen internationalen organisiert. Das ist sozusagen die Sache. Aber das hat jetzt nichts explizit mit diesem einen Produkt zu tun. Und der Kevin, der ist ja nochmal der Typ, der auch in diesem Intro-Video am Anfang war, der früher mal Adobe Flash gemacht hat, den sie dann für die Watch geholt haben. Der hat ja die ganzen letzten anderen Apple Watch Präsentationen gemacht und der war jetzt quasi nur am Anfang. Naja, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen Criminology, Apple Criminology.
Criminology, wie heißt das? Criminology. Criminology, so war das. Ich weiß nicht, welche Nase das jetzt vorstellt, das ist doch nicht so wichtig. Wichtig ist, dass das Video mit Johnny Ive und der Aluminium sagt.
Das könnte ja sein, dass Jeff Williams der nächste Kronprinz ist für den Hauptjob. Wenn Tim das nicht machen will. Kann ich mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Also es wäre Zeit, dass es mal jemand macht, der mehr Produktverständnis hat.
So schlecht sind sie ja gar nicht. Wenn sie den Max gefixt bekommen. Also kurz mal Fakten runterbeten. Was haben wir gehört? Es gibt ein neues iPhone X, wie sie so schön sagen. Xs in der Variante, wie wir es schon kennen. Plus einer Variante, wie wir es noch nicht kennen, nämlich größer. Kann man sich irgendwie Gold und Silber und Grau kaufen. Und hinten ist wieder tolles Glas drauf. Und es ist super wasserresistent und was nicht alles. Der Bildschirm hat noch mal mehr Auflösung. Und es ist überhaupt eine More-Range.
Du nimmst es nicht ernst genug, habe ich das Gefühl.
Ich versuche mich nur auf die wichtigen Sachen zu konzentrieren.
Alles klar.
der Support. Dann gibt es...... wider Stereo Sound. Ich meine, was soll denn das heißen? Wider Stereo Sound. Also sie meinen ja, Lautsprecher wäre toller. Schön, super, was aber wirklich richtig ist.
Ist bei einem größeren Phone jetzt auch nicht schwer, größere Lautsprecher einzubauen.
Na, es geht ja auch für das gleich große Phone.
So wie ich es verstanden hab, vor allen Dingen um das... Wie heißt das? 10S Max.
Nee, das andere auch.
Nee, das war bei den anderen. Bevor sie das Max erwähnt haben, haben sie das irgendwie schon...
Sobald ich weiß. Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig.
Ist auch nicht so wichtig. Na ja, aber toll ist halt, auch wenn es keine große Überraschung ist, nächste Generation ihrer Prozessoren. Das macht mich immer so ein bisschen Chip... Das macht mich spitz, weil... Sie ja jetzt hier dick rumgeprallt haben, dass sie auf sieben Nanometer gegangen ist. Was echt kleines.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder der Hauptgrund, warum sie so bemerkenswerte Werte da erzielen. Gar nicht so sehr im CPU-Bereich. Da meinten sie nämlich, sie seien nur irgendwie 15 Prozent schneller. Das ist jetzt nicht so viel. Aber trotz dieser Geschwindigkeitssteigerung 40 Prozent weniger Stromverbrauch. Und das haben sie dann gleich in ihre GPU wieder installiert. Das ist nochmal 50 Prozent schneller geworden.
Und in den Bionic-Part, oder wie haben sie den genannt?
Genau, diese Neural Engine. Das hatten sie ja letztes Mal schon dabei. Deswegen heißt es ja Bionic. Komischer Name, aber immerhin. Haben sie einen, ist eine 8-Core-Maschine, macht irgendwie allen möglichen crazy shit. Und ist, was sagten sie vorher? 0,6 Trillionen, jetzt 5 Trillionen, also irgendwie so achtmal so viel.
Billionen, auf Deutsch Billionen.
Genau, Trillionen sind Billionen, also 0,6 Trillionen. Genau. Und sie können mit dem neuen Prozessor dann auch mal eben 512 GB Storage unterstützen, was sie dann auch als Option haben. Das kostet dann irgendwie 1600 Euro oder so das Phone. Ein paar zerquetschte.
Die Preise sind langsam ein bisschen unklar.
Eine halbes Terabyte in einem Telefon. Wahnsinn!
Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt so weit.
Wie viele Podcasts man da speichern kann.
Was ich aber nicht so richtig verstehe, ist, warum sie nicht mehr die 128 anbieten. Weil ich finde halt so 64, jo, ist klein und knuffig. Und 256 sind mir halt schon wieder so ein bisschen zu viel. Und diese 128er finde ich eigentlich so...
Ja, aber genau deswegen tun sie das ja.
Ach so.
Damit du nicht die 64 nimmst, sondern die 1 größer. Das wär zu einfachen.
Na ja gut, ich meine, für normale Anwender liest sich das als, du kriegst 200 mehr und dann kriegst du nochmal so 250 mehr. Die Abstände sind eigentlich klar. Du kriegst immer so irgendwie so um 250 mehr. Irgendwas mit 200. Und mal ehrlich, diese kleinste Variante ist für Leute, die eigentlich gar nicht groß Dinge speichern auf dem Telefon. Und das gilt jetzt, wo iCloud so stark ist, eigentlich in zunehmendem Maße für die meisten. Früher war das noch ein Problem beim iPhone, aber jetzt sind so viele Speicheroptimierungsgeschichten drin. Du brauchst viel Speicher, wenn du viele große Spiele hast. Dicke, fette Apps, dafür brauchst du das. Und die auch alle benutzt und die lagern sich ja nach einer Weile jetzt auch wieder aus. Du brauchst es, wenn du viel Video aufnehmen willst. Dafür ist es wirklich sinnvoll. Da macht auch die 512 Gigabyte Option Sinn, also wenn du jetzt 4K Video mit 60 Frames machst, das Ding pumpt da auch Gigabyteweise Daten in den Speicher rein. Das kannst du natürlich nicht so schnell hochladen. Da macht es dann auch Sinn, richtig viel zu kaufen. Aber wenn du jetzt, der Unterschied zwischen 64 und 128 ist eigentlich marginal. Das bringt dir dann auch nichts.
Vielleicht ist dann mittlerweile die 64 Version und dann für 2 Euro die 50 Gigabyte-I-Cloud-Storage dazuholen. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich immer noch die günstigere Variante.
2 Euro würde ich 10 Euro ausgeben. Ich würde schon mehr das Terabyte holen.
Genau, wenn man es braucht. Wenn man aber z.B. nur wenig Sachen braucht, dann skaliert es dir dann je nachdem, wie viel du verbrauchst.
Du willst ja deine Backups drin haben und deine Fotos in der Cloud haben, weil es macht keinen Sinn, dass es auf dem Telefon hängen bleibt.
Macht es ja nichts, es ist auf meinem Rechner. Ich synchronisiere sie in der Tat nicht mit der Cloud, sondern nur mit meinem Rechner. Warum sollte ich meine Fotos in die Cloud schieben?
Damit sie auf allen Rechnern überall immer verfügbar sind und du sie eigentlich nirgendwo richtig speichern musst, damit sie dir nicht verloren gehen?
Ich habe zwei Geräte und Backups. Und meistens speichere ich die noch mal separat auf einer anderen Festplatte.
Ich fotografiere Dinge und bin fünf Sekunden später an meinem Mac und mache mit dem Foto schon irgendwas. Also dieses ganze Ranschnüpfeln, Sinken, Warten, das kenne ich gar nicht mehr. Das ist für mich die Vergangenheit. Alles muss immer überall sein.
Ich habe meine Fotos, die ich ganz besonders toll und schärenswert finde auf Lickr. Alle anderen habe ich auch nicht in der Cloud. Bist nicht allein.
Ich kenne das, ist ja auch okay, kann man ja auch so machen. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall für die meisten Leute vollkommen ausreichend. Zurück zum iPhone. Da haben sie viel rumgepostet mit Machine Learning und da machen sie ja auch schöne Sachen. Die Demos, die sie dann gezeigt haben, waren also okay, also diesen aktuellen Schieß mich tot Game der Woche interessiert mich irgendwie immer nicht. Wer mag, kann da viel schönes bei rauslesen. Aber dann dieses Homecourt. Diese App, das fand ich ja schon jetzt mal.
Das war die mit dem Basketballmensch.
Das war eine App, wo du dein Telefon auf ein Stativ stellst, auf deinen Basketballcourt, wo du rumspringst, einstellst, sodass alle Linien zu sehen sind. Dann hüpfst du da rum und das Ding erkennt, wie du einen Ball in den Basketballkorb reinwirkst.
Sie haben ein Skelett der Person. Ein komplettes Skelett, was sehr interessant ist.
Sie checken das Movement der Person, des Balls, wo du abgesprungen bist, ob der Ball ins Netz gegangen ist oder nicht. Also wie zuverlässig das funktioniert, keine Ahnung. Aber wenn das auch nur ansatzweise funktioniert, ist das schon ziemlich krass. Und ich muss auch sagen, bei AR bin ich immer noch so ein bisschen im Zweifel, wie viele Leute davon wirklich einen Nutzen haben. Ich bin mir immer noch nicht so sicher, ob jeder da was von hat, aber das ist definitiv eine Anwendung, die zählt.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob es Taler war, die das mal gesagt haben, weil ich halt auch so am Ranten war und als Roddy gerade meinte, ich hab mit AR rumgespielt, ich so, und was Sinnvolles? Solange viele Leute damit rumspielen und sei es halt nur für irgendwelche komischen Spiele oder wie jetzt, das ist ja auch was Sinnvolleres, irgendwie so sein Training zu optimieren, selbst wenn man nicht Profibasketballspieler ist, ist das ja schon geil. Dadurch, dass viele Leute viel einfach rumprobieren, kommen vielleicht wenigstens auch ein paar Apps dabei raus, die irgendwie mehr als nur dieses Spiel zum Beispiel wiederum sind. Aber das ist ja kein AR-Spiel gewesen.
Ich muss sagen, das war schon faszinierend mit diesem AR-Kit zu spielen. Also ich kann es ja mal kurz beschreiben. Wir hatten so drei Tage in der Firma so Innovation Days, wird das immer genannt, das ist im Prinzip ein Hackathon, wo jeder mitmachen kann, der da mitmachen möchte. Und die Anwendung, die ich mir angeguckt hab, war halt Autos so zu fotografieren, dass du halt rennst mit dem Phone einmal ums Auto rum und hast hinterher so ein Video, wo du durch scrubben kannst, wo du dann das Auto von allen Seiten sehen kannst. Das Dumme ist, wenn du das tatsächlich mit einem Phone machst und versuchst das Phone auf dieses Auto zu richten und dann einmal außen rum zu rennen, dann bekommst du ein dermaßen shaky Video. Das ist einfach ganz, ganz schlimm. Und die meisten Algorithmen haben auch Probleme, dieses Shaken wieder zu entfernen, weil die normalerweise darauf ausgerichtet sind, den Hintergrund zu erkennen und den Hintergrund zu stabilisieren. Du willst aber ja das Auto im Vordergrund stabilisieren, während sich der Hintergrund dreht, weil du ja die ganze Zeit um das Ding rumrennst. Und meine Idee war jetzt, man macht eine AR-App, wo du halt sagen kannst, da ist mein Auto. Dann hast du so eine Box, da steht dein Auto drin und dann hast du halt die Koordinate von dem Auto. Und dieses AR gibt dir halt die Koordinaten deiner Welt, gibt dir die Koordinaten, wo das Auto ist. Und am interessantesten gibt dir halt die Koordinaten von deiner Kamera, wo ist die Kamera in der Welt, die es erkannt hat. Und auch die Winkel, wie ist deine Kamera rotiert. Das heißt, du kannst dann sagen, in meinem Foto ist die Mittelpunkt des Autos an der Stelle. Und dann kannst du den Mittelpunkt in die Mitte schieben, damit das Auto immer in der Mitte ist. Und dann kannst du noch sagen, wie ist denn der Winkel von der Kamera, wie habe ich denn die gehalten? Und entsprechend den Horizont gerade rotieren. Und das Ergebnis war erstaunlich gut. Also für zwei Tage oder zweieinhalb Tage hacken hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass man so dermaßen smoothe Bilder damit hinkriegt. Also insofern, solche Sachen, da wird es, glaube ich, noch mehr geben. Es ist einfach, ich fand es super, super faszinierend, dass es so gut und so robust funktioniert. Also, ansonsten bin ich jetzt auch nicht so der AR-Tiger. Ein Kollege hat mir dann erzählt, bei der letzten Firma, wo er gearbeitet hat, da haben die für irgendeinen Laden, haben die so eine AR-Anwendung gebaut, wo du, weil die nicht so viele Beacons aufhängen wollten, so Marker haben sie überall, so Bildchen, die sich gut erkennen lassen, hingehängt. Und dann kannst du per AR guckst du dann und dann sieht das AR, okay, da ist der Marker, dann befindest du dich also da und da in dem Laden. Und wenn du jetzt das und das Teil haben willst, dann zeigt er dir eine Route an, die du durch den Laden nehmen kannst, weil dieser Laden wohl so viel Kleinkram hat, dass du das nicht auf Anhieb findest.
Geil wäre es, wenn du vorher schon deine Route, also wenn du vorher deine ganzen Objekte, die du brauchst, definieren kannst, und danach bekommst du die ideale Route durch den Markt.
Ja, das hat dann nicht mehr so viel mit AR zu tun.
Aber ich meine so rein aus der Annoyance-Perspektive, wer nicht gerne einkaufen geht.
Ja, der Informatiker optimiert eben gerne.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich finde auf jeden Fall AR potenziell interessanter als VR.
Ich auch, ehrlich gesagt. Gut, die ganzen Sachen, die man so sieht, dieses Lego-Gedöns und dass du irgendwie bei BMW dann i3 ins Wohnzimmer stellen kannst oder bei IKEA irgendwie die Lampes-Möhre-Brett, das ist jetzt irgendwie, finde ich jetzt nicht so spannend.
Oder den Stuhl Kimme.
Auch diese Galaga AR-Version fand ich eigentlich ganz pfiffig. Also ich habe dem letzten Mal noch nicht ganz so geglaubt, dass das Potenzial hat, aber diese neue Funktionalität in diesem AR-Kit 2, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig mit mehreren Phones sich einen gemeinsamen VR-Space teilen, den du dann über AR in das Bild rein-süngst. Das ist schon irgendwie ganz feist.
Also das war schön ein bisschen. Da gab es zur WWDC von Apple so ein Sample-Projekt, wo du zu zweit spielen kannst, wenn du einen großen Tisch hast. Dann wird so eine Art Steinschleudern eingeblendet und ganz viele Bausteine. Und dann spielst du halt gegeneinander und musst die Schleudern vom anderen mit deinen Kugeln wegschießen. Das ist ganz lustig, haben wir in der Firma ein paar Mal gespielt.
G-Wing-Curling könnte man damit machen.
Aber nicht, dass du auswählend dein iPhone über den G-Wing shuttest.
Ich glaube, da ist noch viel Experimentierung am Start und die Leute müssen halt einfach rausfinden, was geht und was halt irgendwie keinen Sinn macht. Also gerade so AR mit einem iPad zum Beispiel geht halt gar nicht. Dafür ist es halt viel zu schwer. Du hast zwar einen riesen schönen Bildschirm, einen großen, aber das hältst du halt irgendwie fünf Minuten und dann denkst du dir so, ach komm.
Ja zum Beispiel so in, ich könnte mir sowas für so Head-Up-Displays in Fahrzeugen auch sehr gut vorstellen. Wenn du dann irgendwie schon kommst, so an so eine Parklücke zum Beispiel rangefahren, kriegst du dann sofort gleich eingeblendet, so groß ist die in dein Auto, passt da so rein und kriegst halt so alles so reingeschnackt.
Das ist auch was, worauf ich mich wirklich sehr freue, wenn so diese Head-Up-Displays-Teile, also wirklich so integriert in dein Auto sind, wirklich so fester Bestandteil. Weil ich bin letztes Jahr mit einem Auto gefahren, wo einer nicht fest eingebaut war, ich glaube, der hat einen Kickstarter gebacked damals, um so ein System dazu zu bekommen. Und ich bin halt mit dem Auto gefahren und das ist super angenehm, wenn du nur so einen kleinen Hinweis irgendwie auf deiner Scheibe siehst, so ok, du musst dich jetzt schon mal links einordnen, weil du willst irgendwie an der Autobahn diese Abfahrt dann nehmen. Wie entspannt Auto fahren wird, wenn du halt nicht nur auf dieses Gequatsche hören musst von Google Maps oder Apple Maps.
Oder immer so deinen Blickfokus ändern.
Ja, genau. Also gerade so auf der Autobahn ist das irgendwie eher so unangenehm.
Oder geil wär doch auch, du fährst mit dem Rad und der trackt schon von weitem die Ampelphasen und kann dir dann direkt einblenden, ne, fahr mal jetzt irgendwie 3 kmh langsam und dann kriegst du genau die grüne Phase.
Da erinnere ich mich gleich dran, als ich noch an der Uni war, gab es, hat dem Projekt angefangen, ich weiß nicht ob mit Airbus, wo es um die Visualisierung von Wetter im Flieger gab. Wo du natürlich auch, wenn du da diesen Hats-up-Display weiterdenkst, du irgendwie fliegst dein Flugzeug als Pilot und der sagt dir da hinten so, oh nee, Gewitter im Anmarsch, flieg mal da lang.
Auch fürs Segeln interessant.
Oder fürs Segeln, genau. Da hast du aber nicht so einen Bildschirm vor dir, so eine Scheibe.
Ja, brauchst du halt die...
Das ist dann deine Apple Watch, die dir das...
Apple Glasses. Wie auch immer.
Jetzt haben wir hier ganz euphorisch über das iPhone geredet und der Tim ist ganz ruhig geworden.
Er bestellt gerade China Infotainment-Systeme.
Was ich irgendwie lustig finde...
Du musst ja nicht zu allem was sagen, oder?
Bist du sicher?
Bist du sicher, Tim?
Natürlich bin ich mir sicher.
Soll ich zu allem was sagen?
Produktbezeichnung... Ich würde mich manchmal freuen auszureden.
Ich würde mir lieber deine Kekse rüber. Welche?
Das sind die, die süchtig machen, ne?
Ich mache auch Mikro aus.
Wir waren ja schon bei diesen ganzen Produktbezeichnungen. Ich finde irgendwie, dieses iPhone Xs Max ist schon irgendwie interessant. Dann dieses Super Retina Display und dann noch den Liquid Retina Display.
Ja, das habe ich auch nicht verstanden, warum das eine Super Retina und das andere Liquid Retina ist. Warum ist das jetzt Liquid Retina, weil es LCD ist?
Wahrscheinlich. Das Super Retina ist doch OLED vom Xs. Und das andere ist ja die günstigere Variante.
Das LCD ist ja Liquid Crystal, deswegen ist es Liquid Retina.
Siehst du mal, ganz einfach, das macht schon Sinn.
Das ist sozusagen der Liquid Retina Liquid Crystal Display.
Sozusagen.
Vielleicht sollten wir zu diesem Xs noch kurz anmerken, dass auch die Kamera sich nochmal ganz toll verbessert hat, ihre Angabe nach. Sie haben da einige bemerkenswerte Sachen gezeigt, unter anderem auch diese krasse Geschichte mit, dass du nicht nur jetzt so Death of Field Fotos machen kannst, sondern das auch noch nachträglich bearbeiten kannst. Was mir dann allerdings komplett die Schuhe ausgezogen hat, ist, als sie dann dieses Xr-iPhone auch noch vorgestellt haben, dessen Platz mir irgendwie noch nicht so ganz klar ist, weil es in der Größe zwischen dem Xs und dem Xs Max, was für ein Scheißnamen, ist, also kleiner hätte ich ja irgendwie verstanden, aber so unklar.
Aber bei den Fotos, da noch mal vielleicht hin, dass du nachträglich die Blende ändern kannst mit dem Hintergrund, also die haben einen Hintergrund.
Das meinte ich ja gerade, das ist Death of Fear.
Ach so, okay, sorry, dann hab ich das gerade noch nicht gehört.
Diese bookige Geschichte, das ist ja eingefaked, mehr oder weniger.
Ja, durch die mehreren Bilder, die es macht, oder?
Nö, ja, dadurch, dass sie erkennen, was vorne ist und was hinten ist, durch irgendein Machine Learning, sonst was. Und dann sagen sie einfach, okay, alles, was nicht vorne ist, darauf wenden wir dann den Bokeh-Filter an.
Ja, aber das machen sie halt mittlerweile sehr gut. Das war ja am Anfang noch so ein bisschen schwierig. Und gerade diese Fotos mit den Haaren, das ist so ziemlich das Schwerste bei der ganzen Geschichte, das war schon alles ziemlich bemerkenswert. Nur, mein Verständnis davon war bisher immer, dass diese Doppelkamera erforderlich ist, um diese Death of Field-Geschichte zu machen. Und danach haben sie dieses Xr vorgestellt, was nur eine Kamera hat und dasselbe macht.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich so, wie sie halt 3D in Filme rendern, weil die meisten Filme, die 3D sind, werden ja auch mit einer normalen Kamera gedreht. Und das wird nur aus den Schatteninformationen dann das 3D-Bild generiert.
Wie ist denn das, die Kamera? Ist das eine mechanische Fokuskamera? Oder ist das eine Fest-Fix-Fokus-Kamera? Also wenn die einen mechanischen Fokus macht, dann könnten sie ja relativ schnell das Fokus-Field durchfahren und sich merken, was ist wann, wo in Fokus, um das dann hinterher quasi nochmal mit ein bisschen Spezialtricks...
Ich vermute, die rendern das einfach.
Vielleicht habe ich irgendwas nicht mitbekommen, aber das war mir auf jeden Fall unklar.
Und das mit diesem Depth of Field, das finde ich ja auch ganz interessant, weil es gab ja vor langer Zeit, einige Jahre, diese Litro, hieß die doch Kamera, die quasi gar nicht mehr so Shutter-basiert arbeitete, sondern einfach auch die ganze Zeit so Lichtaufnahmen und man konnte da nicht nur die Depth of Field ändern, sondern sogar den Fokuspunkt ändern.
Ja, das war irgendwie diese Lichtfeldkamera, oder wie das hier hieß. Wo dann eine Weile lang alle gesagt haben, das ist jetzt die Zukunft, alles andere stirbt aus. Aber dann hat man doch nicht mehr so viel davon.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie war mir so, als wären die Entwickler dann auch in irgendwie aller Herren Länder quasi zerstreut gewesen. Und wer weiß, vielleicht ist ja irgendjemand bei Apple gelandet und hat sie dann dazu inspiriert, das dann einfach in ein Software zu machen. Aber ja, mehr davon. Also weil diese Lytro-Kamera, die fand ich ja... Also da dachte ich auch so, genau das will man haben. Und es gibt so einige Entwicklungen in der digitalen Kamerawelt, die so gerade so an der Kante zum In den Markt springen sind. Zum Beispiel hat Canon, glaube ich jetzt vor 2 oder 3 Jahren, einen Sensor gedemod, mit dem man sozusagen die Lichtstärke eines menschlichen Auges quasi auch in der Kamera hat. Das heißt, man kann Sterne fotografieren und so weiter ohne lange Belichtungszeiten. Also die war einfach ultra gut in Dunkelheit ohne Rauschen. Und die sollte jetzt eigentlich schon rauskommen. Sie hatten also eine Demokamera und haben das auch vorgeführt. Darauf warte ich, dass man jetzt endlich mal im 21. Jahrhundert Bilder im Dunkeln machen kann ohne Rauschen. Ich meine, die Apple-Kameras werden in den Phones auch schon immer besser. Aber diese Canon-Kamera, die war schon so richtig im Mundklappe auf. Und dann halt sowas wie dieses Depth of Field oder Fokuspunkt nach hinein ändern. Das wären schon alles so Features, wo man wirklich mal dann hier die großen Worte aus den Apple-Keynote gerechtfertigt anwenden kann.
Dann machen sie noch so Kram, mit HDR. Das sah natürlich alles ganz beeindruckend aus, wie das immer so ist in solchen Präsentationen. Das muss man sich auch noch mal genauer von jemand anschauen lassen, der davon was versteht. Aber man merkt schon, das ist schon ein bisschen irre, was diese Telefone mittlerweile machen, nur um ein Foto zu schießen. Also der Aufwand ist ja echt enorm. Und dass sie da auch diese ganze Machine-Learning-Geschichte mit reinbringen, finde ich irre. Also das ganze Gesicht erkennen und so weiter. Und das dann auch noch in diesem Depths of Field mit einrechnen. Also unter Umständen machen sie wirklich sozusagen über Bilderkennung, diese ganze Tiefe. So was ist jetzt hier eigentlich im Vordergrund etc. Also das ist mir noch ein bisschen unklar. Aber auch diese ganze HDR-Geschichte mit. Ich mache mal gleichzeitig verschiedene Fotos mit unterschiedlichen Blendeneinstellungen oder Belichtungszeiten. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was sie da variieren. Und dann setzen wir quasi in Echtzeit ein Composite-Foto zusammen, was best of all variants ist. Ich hatte jetzt im Urlaub relativ viel so Bergekram und Himmel und Wolken. Und was da HDR macht, ist schon bemerkenswert. Das scheint auch alles nicht schlechter geworden zu sein.
Also wirklich eine Sache, die man sehr beobachten kann, ist, dass wirklich jetzt die Smartphone-Kameras, also nicht nur im iPhone, schon wirklich so gut sind, dass einige Freunde, die sonst immer eine Kamera für alle Gelegenheiten dabei hatten, auch teilweise ehemalige professionelle Fotografen, einfach sagen, also wenn ich eine wirkliche Zoom-Linse brauche oder so was, oder einen Tele, dann vielleicht ja, aber ansonsten mach ich jetzt auch alles nur noch mit dem Telefon. Das ist schon auch sehr beachtlich.
Ja, das ist für mich auch so der einzige Grund, warum ich zu so einem neueren Telefon tendieren würde. In der Tat, Kamera-Feature.
Ja, und auch diese IP68-Schutzklasse, die sie da jetzt erreicht haben, das ist, ich hab gerade nochmal nachgeschaut, das ist schon so ziemlich das Maximale, was du in so ein Produkt überhaupt eingebaut bekommen kannst. Das einzige, wie man das noch steigern könnte, wäre noch Schutz gegen Wasser bei Hochdruck-Dampfstrahlreinigung. Speziell Landwirtschaft.
Ja, ein Kollege, hallo, Grüße an den Kollegen, der hat ja es gewagt, sein Telefon, sein X unter den Wasserhahn zu halten, um es zu reinigen, was dem Gerät nicht gut getan hat. Aber Apple hat das mit viel Überredungskunst dann trotzdem ersetzt.
Hat danach nicht funktioniert?
Das ist aber schon die zweite Geschichte, die ich jetzt mittlerweile höre von dem X.
Aber angeblich soll das doch wasserdicht sein.
Genau, unter Wasserhahn ist vielleicht noch mal ein anderer Film.
Tja, was halten wir jetzt davon?
Ja, wenn ich jetzt nicht das X schon hätte, würde ich das andere auch mir von meinem Arbeitgeber bezahlen lassen.
Also es gibt natürlich jetzt noch einen Feature, das haben wir noch überhaupt nicht erwähnt.
Genau, das ist es halt.
Stimmt.
Beziehungsweise verbunden damit eSIM.
Aber jetzt alle drei neuen Phones, ne?
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, alle Phones, das Xr und die Xs-Serie, haben alle Dual Sim, sie haben nach wie vor nur einen Kartenslot.
Da tritt Apple mal wieder gegen das Schienenbein der Provider, ne?
Ja, ich fand's merkwürdig, sie haben ja explizit noch mal gesagt, dass sie in China eine Dual Sim mit zwei SIM-Karten haben, warum auch immer.
Das muss eine Regulationssache in China sein, weil anders ist nicht zu erklären.
Das kann sehr gut sein, aber genau weiß ich es nicht. Tatsache ist, für USA und Europa gibt's eSIM. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, kannst du halt so ein Telefon nehmen und erst mal ganz normal wieder eine SIM-Karte reinstecken, wie gehabt. Du kannst ja aber auch eine eSIM holen. Die Frage ist, wo kriegt man die her? Wenn das so läuft wie bei der Apple Watch, davon gehe ich ja eigentlich aus. Da haben sie das im Prinzip das erste Mal verbaut.
Da haben wir was von QR-Code erzählt.
Genau, da hast du nämlich da so ein Autorisierungscode und darüber wird dann diese eSIM initialisiert. Das heißt, das ist ein Prozess, den ein Provider unterstützen muss. Im Prinzip tut die Telekom das ja schon mit der Watch. Und wurde davon wahrscheinlich auch. Und dann wird es letztlich genauso funktionieren oder ähnlich funktionieren für das Telefon. Könnte also bedeuten, weiß ich ja natürlich nicht, wie das jetzt laufen wird, dass man, wenn man sich so ein Telefon kauft, kann man erstmal seine normale SIM-Karte reinstecken, dann geht es. Aber man müsste dann eigentlich auch die Möglichkeit haben zu sagen, okay, liebe Telekom, jetzt bitte mal hier das Ding als eSIM hier rein, damit ich die andere SIM-Karte wieder rausnehmen kann. Und dann hat man einen freien Slot.
Das könnte uns ja unser Freak Show verbundener Tele-Tea-Mobile-Shop-Mitarbeiter vielleicht mal...
Das können wir sicherlich dem nicht rausfinden. Die Telekom müsste sich ja da zu äußern. Aber so habe ich es verstanden und das würde dann bedeuten, dass du eben so einen richtigen Kartenslot frei hast. Und sprich, wenn man jetzt hier ins Ausland fährt, könnte man sich mal problemlos eine zweite Karte reinklicken, ohne gleich diesen ganzen Affenscheiß zu haben mit, oh, ja, hier neue Telefonnummer und iMessage und jetzt hier nicht mehr verbunden. Das ist doch wirklich ein Affenscheiß, wenn du das mal gemacht hast.
Wahrscheinlich ist es der Fix genau dafür, weil Apple das anders nicht hinkriegt. Muss jetzt die Hardware-Division lösen.
Glaub ich nicht. Ich glaub, dass es einfach einen extremen Demand gab danach und dass gerade diese Leute im Ausland immer wieder ein echtes Problem hatten. Und sie wollen natürlich einfach unter ihrer Nummer erreichbar sein und sie wollen ihre Bindings, die an dieser Telefonnummer dranhängen, WhatsApp und so weiter, auch behalten.
Tim Cook war im Ausland und schon gibt's eine Dual-SIM.
Ich glaub, dem Tim Cook-Trang sind zweifelnde Sendemast hinterher.
Auf jeden Fall wird das bedeuten, dass wir demnächst mehr e-SIMs sehen werden oder vor allen Dingen weniger SIMs.
Ja, hoffentlich vor allen Dingen in den Ländern, wo man hinfährt. Da sagt man dann halt einfach hier e-SIM.
Miep. Ich frage mich auch, wie viele SIMs kann man da reinladen?
Na ja, mal ganz ehrlich, wenn's nur ein QR-Code ist.
In der UI waren zwei Sachen zu sehen, Primär- und Sekundärnummern.
Ja, schon, aber ich glaube, weitere e-SIMs sind wahrscheinlich nur ein Software-Update entfernt.
Das ist aber nicht ein reines Software-Feature.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber du kannst natürlich theoretisch die SIM ja quasi rausnehmen, die e-SIM. Dann wird die irgendwo abgespeichert und dann kannst du eine andere rein tun. Dann ist die in dem e-SIM-Sockel drin und dann schon hast du die SIMs getauscht.
Das ist ja keine e-SIM, das ist ja so eine VM, die da drin ist, wo quasi die Karte drin läuft.
Ja, richtig.
Du musst ja die Karte da quasi in so einem isolierten Stück Elektronik abfeiern.
Richtig, nur du kannst die ja löschen und kannst dann eine andere rein tun und kannst dir aber merken, wie du die erste da rein getan hast, nämlich durch den QR-Code. Den Code kannst du ja merken und kannst dir sagen, jetzt hätte ich aber gerne die wieder reingesteckt.
Ich weiß ja nicht so ganz genau, ob das so reproduzierbar ist.
Warum denn nicht?
Weil wegen Sicherheit irgendwas, also …Na du brauchst wahrscheinlich hier noch eine Pin dazu oder so. Na ja, es wäre jetzt auch nicht falsch, wenn man da zwei oder mehr eSIM-Slots hätte und dann kann man halt einfach viele Telefone telefonieren nach oben.
Sie müssen für das iPhone, wie wird das da nachheißen? iPhone T, nach S kommt T, R, S, T, iPhone X, T, Y, Z …Da müssen sie ja auch noch Features vorhalten. Oder heißt es dann 11?
Oder heißt es dann V?
Auf jeden Fall ist jetzt alles X.
Nein, der V wäre fünf.
Ja, bei Apple scheint es ja irgendwie bei zehn, hören die ja oft zu zählen.
Danach gibt es kein iPhone mehr.
Oder ist es dann jetzt ein J-Phone oder weiß ich nicht, was sie dann weiterzählen?
Mir ist auch vollkommen unklar, wie sie da jetzt noch weiter machen wollen. X, 10, ich meine, liest irgendjemand da ein 10 draus? Ich glaube, es sind die Einzigen, die es so nennen.
Die Römer.
Xs, Max, Max. An dieser Stelle Grüße an Max. Apple hat jetzt sogar noch ein Telefon nach dir benannt. Ist doch schön.
Die haben ihm nicht nur die Watch gebaut, sondern auch noch ein Telefon.
Genau, großer Visionär.
Das hast du gut gemacht.
Nächstes Jahr dann bitte das iPhone Tim.
10 gibt es schon, dann das iPhone Tim.
Ja, Tim und Tim S und Tim Max. Dann haben wir alle beisammen. Und iPhone, iPhone Huckel, X Huckel.
Trikorder, ich sag nur iPhone 3.
Was soll denn der Trikorder machen?
Alles.
Heilen?
Naja, das wäre natürlich jetzt schon so richtig Zukunft. Also da können sie dann wirklich Groundbreaking.
Das war aber nicht der Trikorder, der geheilt hat, das war noch mal ein super Abzeichen, die weiß.
Das geht eher mir darum, ich will die ganze Welt erfahren mit Daten. Also das, was jetzt zum Beispiel mit der Uhr nicht geht, wegen das Ding macht Wärme, dein Körper macht Wärme, so ein Temperatursensor. Klingt jetzt nicht nach Raketenwissenschaft, ist aber in der Uhr nicht möglich, im Telefon schon eher. Magnetfeldsensor, Strahlensensor, geil. Laser-Distanz-Messung hatte ich ja schon angesprochen, super. All diese ganzen Sachen, hier dieses, es gab doch diesen Kickstarter mit dem Spektrometer.
Laser-Distanz-Messer, ich bitte dich, das wird nicht kommen, Mann.
Ja, aber ich will's.
Also Temperatur könnten sie wahrscheinlich sogar messen, mit Infrarot und so weiter. Du hast nur das Problem, dass du am Handgelenk nicht die Körpertherm-Temperatur hast.
Du kannst halt deine eigene Temperatur nicht messen, das wär halt geil bei der Uhr.
Ach so, dass du die Außentemperatur...
Aber wenn du Außentemperatur da auch hier von irgendwelchen Objekten messen kannst, warum nicht? Also das sollte ja gehen mit Infrarot.
Oh ja, so eine Thermokamera im iPhone.
Und wie gesagt, hier so ein Strahlen-Messgerät. Geil, dann sagt ja die Uhr Achtung. Du bist jetzt hier gerade in der Tschernobyl-Zone, geh auch mal drei Schritte wieder zurück, da war besser.
Das kommt sobald in Amiland einer der 600 Kernreaktoren hochgeht.
So, jetzt guck ich mal, was der Spaß kostet.
Zu viel.
Ich klick mir jetzt mal hier.
Im Chat sagt einer Huckel will ein iPhone-Batch, ne Tim will das iPhone-Batch, The Bachelor.
Ja, ich find die Preise schon sehr stabil, muss ich sagen.
Ja, also hätte ich das nicht vom Arbeitgeber bekommen, hätte ich es wahrscheinlich mir auch nicht selber gekauft, aber ich bin sehr froh, dass es mir gekauft wurde, weil es wirklich nach wie vor mein Lieblings-iPhone ist.
Also man kann 1550 Euro ausgeben für das dicke, fette...
Oh, jetzt bist du ja bei dem X-Max, oder?
Das Maxi...
Das X-Max in halbem Terabyte...
X-Maxi kostet 1649 Euro, also nochmal ein Hundi mehr. Klar kann man das von der Steuer absetzen.
Ich bin ein Jahres...
Aber nicht so einfach. Nee, das stimmt. Das ist ein echtes Problem. Das geht aber mittlerweile hier mit überhaupt gar keinem iPhone mehr.
Mit dem 8er.
Das R vielleicht noch oder die ganz alten.
Nee, mit dem 8 kann man das jetzt machen.
Was kostet denn das R?
Bei 999 los.
Wirklich?
Oder 800? 850? Guck an.
850.
Dann gibt's das nicht mal in Gold. Guck mal, da gibt's die 128er-Variante. Na ja, was ist nicht in Gold?
Na die Farbe ist glaube ich, ach so, na ja, da gibt's kein Gold.
Ja, jetzt hab ich mich so an das Gold gewöhnt.
Wirklich? Tja, also iPhone schnell absetzen, schwierig. Da muss man dann irgendwie so einen Android kaufen, dafür kann man besser absetzen. Endlich mal ein Vorteil der Plattform.
Oder dann halt, du gehst dann in diesen 2-Jahres-Rhythmus, gehst dann zu Apple Giveback, oder 1-Jahres-Rhythmus, dann hast du immer pro Jahr so deine...
Stimmt, es gibt ja noch dieses Apple-Abo, gibt es das noch?
Auf jeden Fall hat Telekom auch so was. Aber nee, das finde ich ist zu verschwenderisch.
Wieso? Es wird ja weiter benutzt von anderen Leuten.
Ja, aber ich könnte das halt auch dann meiner Mutter geben.
Die kann dir ja dann auch 850 Euro geben.
Meine Mutter will das Telefon gegen den Kopf werfen, aber nicht die 800 Euro geben.
Was ja irre ist, ist, seitdem sie das 10 rausgebracht haben, macht ja Apple noch mehr Geld pro iPhone. Wie heißt das? Der Average Selling Price, ASP. Den geben sie ja immer bekannt, wenn wieder so Quartal ist. Sonst haben wir verkauft und wir haben im Schnitt folgenden Preis erzielt für dieses Telefon und durch das X ist der ja nochmal mega nach oben gegangen. I predict, der geht jetzt noch weiter nach oben. Ich glaube, dass auch von diesem dicken, fetten 512 GB Porn auch nochmal richtig tonnenweise was weggeht. Weil alle Leute, die irgendwie nach einer professionellen 4K-Kamera Ausschau halten, die werden wahrscheinlich sich jetzt einfach so ein iPhone nehmen.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, überziehen sie es jetzt nicht ein bisschen? Also das billigste iPhone, was man jetzt neu kaufen kann, ist iPhone 7 für 520 Euro.
Überziehen, was meinst du mit überziehen? Meinst du das Koffe ist Kacke mehr?
Naja, dass sie zumindest nicht mehr nach unten hin den Markt so weit abdecken, dass jemand, der unbedingt auf die iOS-Plattform will, halt auch ein günstiges Einsteigergerät kriegt.
Na, was ist denn günstig? Na, so um die 250 bis vielleicht? Nein, an dem Markt nehmen sie nicht teil. Haben sie noch nie.
Ja, aber genau, das ist ja vielleicht das Problem.
Hast du den einen oder das Apple ein Problem?
Weißt du, wie viel Prozent des Profits, der weltweit mit Smartphones erzeugt wird, bei Apple landet fast alles.
Moment, was ich gesagt hab, ich frage mich, ob sie es nicht langsam überziehen.
Aber was soll denn passieren? Dass keiner mehr kauft oder was?
Dass sie weiter Marktanteil verlieren. Also in Deutschland haben sie ja nur einen Marktanteil von 10%.
Zuletzt haben sie gewonnen. Der Marktanteil ist Apple scheißegal. Weil in dem Segment, in dem sie unterwegs sind, haben sie wahrscheinlich einen Marktanteil von 90%. Das ist alles, was sie sehen. Guck mal, für Apple ist es doch nur wichtig, als relevante Plattform angesehen zu werden, damit nach wie vor Apps dafür gemacht werden, damit ihre Plattform interessant ist. Das ist das, was sie erreichen müssen. Da sind sie, da werden sie bleiben. Niemand, der heute seriös mit irgendeinem Dienst auf den Markt geht, kann es sich leisten, nicht auf iOS anzubieten. So, damit ist alles erfüllt, was sie brauchen. Jetzt geht es nur noch darum, Geld zu verdienen. Sie nehmen hohe Preise. Ja, aber das ist das Ziel der ganzen Sache. Na ja, schon klar. Leute bezahlen diese Preise. Sie produzieren wahrscheinlich so viele iPhones, wie sie überhaupt nur können. Du kannst diese hochwertigen... Also das will ich erst mal sehen, dass irgendjemand mit solchen Geräten mehr davon überhaupt produzieren kann, mit diesen hochwertigen Komponenten. Die muss ja auch erstmal in der entsprechenden Menge überhaupt zusammendängeln. Und ich glaube, sie produzieren das Maximum, was man überhaupt produzieren kann, und sie verkaufen es zu einem Maximumpreis, zu dem man das verkaufen kann. Und mal ehrlich, wer von so einem iPhone X einen Nutzen hat, für den ist 200 Euro mehr oder weniger vollkommen egal.
Na gut, ich war jetzt gerade beim iPhone 7. Also, was halt, wie gesagt, ein Einstiegspreis von 520 Euro ist schon auch eine Hausnummer. Da kenn ich genug Leute, die sagen, gut, jetzt nicht unser Alter vielleicht, aber die sagen dann, okay, geht nicht. Oder will ich nicht.
Die Masse kauft ja dann auch nicht das Telefon einfach so im Laden zum Neupreis, sondern gesponsert über so einen Vertrag halt. Ich hab mir nie ein iPhone 7 extra gekauft, sondern immer das über Telekom 2-Jahres-Vertrag-Wissen schon abgestottert in diesem Sinne sozusagen. Und da bezahlst du dann halt nicht diese 500, da zahlst du halt eben 200 Euro und dann kriegst du dein iPhone und den Rest bezahlst du über den monateuerten. Und so macht das, glaube ich, eher die breite Masse. Und dann ist es ja auch wieder erschwinglicher. Klar, dass das Modell am Ende nicht besser ist, weiß ich auch schon den Hörer darauf hin, das ist klar, aber so läuft das halt.
Der Chat missversteht uns mal wieder. Zitat, ich finde das ja witzig, dass Apple Fanboys manchmal echt stolz darauf sind, dass Apple eine so unglaubliche Marge hat. Das wäre, als wenn ich mich freue, wenn mein Autoverkäufer mir besonders viel Geld für das Auto berechnet, das er mir verkauft. Ja, falsch. Also erstens sind wir auf gar nichts stolz hier, das ist einfach eine Feststellung. Also das ist einfach eine Korrektur an dem, meiner Meinung nach, falschen Bild, was man hat, wenn man über Marktanteil redet. Apple ist der Marktanteil, über den immer geredet wird, weitgehend wurscht. In dem Markt, den Sie für sich ausgesucht haben, der ein ganz anderer Markt ist als alle Smartphones, sondern alle Smartphones im hochpreisigen Segment, wo man überhaupt hohe Margen nehmen kann, da sind Sie extrem erfolgreich und präsent. Das ist halt einfach so. Autoverkäufer ist im Übrigen kein guter Vergleich, weil hier müsste man es mit dem Autohersteller vergleichen. So, und wenn du mir das Autosegment mal anschaust, da gibt es, also der Vergleich hinkt, aber auch da gibt es ein, ja, er hinkt ein bisschen, ich denke nicht, dass man alles damit vergleichen kann, aber es gibt natürlich Parallelen. Mercedes, BMW, hochpreisige Marken, ich meine, da muss man sich nur mal die Preise anschauen, die die für Ersatzteile nehmen etc. Das sieht da nicht sehr viel anders aus. Man ist bereit, das zu bezahlen, weil man einerseits damit Prestige-Image für sich kauft, ist ja so. Andererseits weiß man auch, dass damit natürlich erst mal eine generelle Qualität auch, also ein gewisser Qualitätslevel gehalten wird, weil sie ja eben auch viel Geld verdienen, können sie sich das auch erlauben, gute Qualität zu bauen. Das ist ja Leuten, manchen Leuten zumindest, beim Auto wichtig, andere sagen, warte, ich kaufe mir ein Panda, fährt auch, hat vier Räder, kann man sich reinsetzen, hat einen Sitz, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Und die anderen sagen, nee, muss aber hier Mercedes-Benz Schnick Schnack XYZ mit irgendwie 5000 PS und Tesla und hast nicht gesehen, das muss es halt alles sein. Das sind einfach unterschiedliche Ansprüche. Andererseits hat das natürlich ja auch alles einen anderen Wert. Ich meine, diese billig Android-Phones, die kannst du nach zwei Jahren auch einfach wegschmeißen. Die wird dir keiner mehr abnehmen. Vielleicht geschenkt. Ein iPhone nach zwei Jahren verkaufst du halt nach wie vor zu einem guten Preis. Und da, also wenn das Ding nicht im Eimer ist, kannst du so, man klickt einfach mal, was alte iPhones auf Ebay bringen. Viel, viel Geld. So, das heißt, wenn du den Verkaufspreis da wieder mit einrechnest, ist das auch gar nicht so teuer.
Ja, muss man nur rechtzeitig verkaufen.
Ja, aber ich kann mein iPhone X auch nächstes Jahr noch für sehr viel Geld verkaufen. Und wenn ich dann den Kaufpreis auf die genutzte Zeit umlege, dann relativiert sich das halt auch extrem. Klar, ist immer das Problem, wenn es kaputt geht und so. Klar, kann ja passieren, aber das Ding hat an sich einen Wert.
Obwohl ich habe lange kein Phone mehr kaputt gemacht.
Übrigens hier, weil wir uns vorhin so über die Mugs und Hyper-, also Liquid Display und so weiter amüsiert hatten. Ich hab hier mal noch, ich werf mal noch kurz ein Foto in den Chat, was ich vor einiger Zeit bei einer Tankstelle gesehen hab, die auch irgendwie mit den Superlative um sich schmissen. Na komm, Slack, Slack, mach es. Ja, da hat Esso nämlich darüber informiert, wie sie jetzt ihre neuen Kraftstoffe nennen.
Schlimmer geht immer.
Das ist noch viel besser. Also Super ist jetzt Super. Synergy Super. Super E10 ist jetzt Synergy Super E10. Super Plus ist jetzt Synergy Supreme Plus Super Plus.
Sind sie noch Liquid eigentlich?
Diesel ist Synergy Diesel. Also aus Super Plus dann Synergy Supreme Plus Super Plus zu machen.
Was soll jetzt das Synergy eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Die ganzen Marketing-Leute, die bei Apple abgelehnt werden.
Aber da hat sich Apple sozusagen noch moderat zurückgehalten, Leute. Mit ihren Superlativen. Innihuse, sollen wir durch da mit diesem Apple?
Im Prinzip lässt sich da nicht mehr so sehr viel mehr sagen.
Wir warten weiterhin auf Apple Pay.
Es gab noch einen kleinen Nachklapp, irgendwie HomePod. Da waren aber nur, das waren jetzt keine neuen wirklichen Features, sondern nur so Software-Features.
Das AirPlay 2, wo man jetzt zwei gleichzeitig als Stereo-Ding sie veranstalten kann.
Ja gut, aber das war ja, gab's ja schon.
Jaja, aber er hat's noch mal erwähnt.
Aber was jetzt kommt, ist nämlich Search by Lyrics. Komischerweise haben sie das nur beim HomePod gesagt. Meines Wissens ist das sozusagen ein Feature, was jetzt generell in Apple Music Einzug hält.
Ja, sicher, klar, wenn sie es können, werden sie es überall machen.
Für eine tolle Sache. Und man kann damit auch telefonieren, wenn man das will.
Ich telefoniere einfach viel zu wenig, als dass das alles irgendwie für mich sinnvoll ist.
Manche Leute tun das. Und Find my iPhone geht auch. Da kann man in HomePod einfach fragen, wo das Telefon ist. Das ist auch schon mal nicht schlecht. Ja, dann dieser Stereo-Mode. Das ist ja alles nicht wirklich was Neues. Das haben sie nur wiederholt. Fand ich aber dann doch, ich war schon für einen kurzen Moment, war ich nämlich in Schock. Weil ich nämlich heute Morgen in so einem Shopping-Urge mir noch einen zweiten HomePod geklickt hab. Oh, ich fass sie an den Kopf. Einen zweiten HomePod.
Ich bin ja nach wie vor, ich bin ja nach wie vor misstrauisch, ob das Teil tatsächlich so gut klingt, wie sie sagen. Weil momentan, ja momentan sind ja alle Geräte, die du irgendwo kaufst, sind basslastig. Und alle sind der Meinung, die müssen so klingen. Und der HomePod ist garantiert auch basslastig. Aber ich hab noch keinen wirklich gehört.
Ich find den überhaupt nicht basslastig.
Ja, was heißt drum? Ich find deine Podcasts zum Beispiel auch basslastig. Aber eh, egal.
Die wollen ja auch so rüberkommen, als wären sie ganz geil.
Ja, sind sie auch zum großen Teil.
Das denkst du nicht durch die Basslastigkeit. Auf jeden Fall, was ich damit eigentlich zum Ausdruck bringen wollte, ist entgegen meiner Erwartung bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit dem Teil.
Du, ich glaube dir sofort, dass man damit zufrieden ist, weil das ist mit den meisten Apple-Produkten, ist man zufrieden, aber da muss man halt gucken, zu welchem Preis. Also...
Ja, ja, aber wenn ich mir jetzt eine gute, brauchbar klingende, sonstige Stereo-Lösung oder Musik-Lösung irgendwo hinbaue, dann kostet mich das mehr.
Ja, ich hab so ein bisschen das Problem, dass ich halt zuhause jetzt Studiomonitore hab. Und dann, wenn du einmal angefangen hast deine Musik nur noch über Studiomonitore zu hören, dann ist es schwierig mit allen anderen, was irgendwie Musik hergibt.
Ja, aber mir reicht diese Qualität vollkommen aus und vor allem diese Flexibilität ist eigentlich ganz geil. Ich muss zugeben, dass sie wirklich mit diesem Werbespot, den sie gemacht haben, den ich neulich schon so...
Mit der Verschiebewand...
.belobigt haben, mit der Verschiebewand.
Der Jamiroquake.
Da haben sie schon sehr den Punkt getroffen, irgendwie wie dieses Produkt funktioniert. Also ich erwisch mich sozusagen morgens genau in diesem Modus. Kaffee, Trane, ich träge irgendwie. Machen wir Musik ein. Dann kommt da noch wieder Musik und es ist okay. Das passt schon.
Ja, die kriegen mich.
Schlimm. Und Mojave gibt es dann demnächst. Und ich hoffe es gibt dann auch bald mal im Max.
Ohne Quatsch. I wouldn't hold my breath. Nachdem sie ja den Mac Pro irgendwie auf 2019 verschoben haben.
Ist ja bald.
Ist ja nicht mehr so lange hin. Da bin ich noch sehr skeptisch, dass sie da liefern. Also da hab ich wirklich Bedenken.
Ja, meiner Meinung nach. Ich meine, jetzt haben sie wieder damit mit Bionic Chip und Machine Learning und bla bla bla gemacht. Und wenn du dir dann anguckst, wenn ich tatsächlich als Entwickler auf einem Apple-System ein neuronales Netz lernen will, dann bin ich total im Wald. Weil es gibt keine Hardware, auf der du ordentlich, die auf dem Mac laufen würde, auf der du ordentlich Machine Learning machen könntest. Da musst du dir dann doch wieder ein Linux PC hinstellen. Mit einer ordentlichen Nvidia Grafikkarte. Da ist meiner Meinung nach, wenn sie dieses Feld beackern wollen, dann müssen sie auch die Tools dafür bereitstellen, aber die sind halt nicht da bei Apple. Also keine Ahnung, wie sie sich das vorstellen.
Übrigens, noch eine große Enttäuschung, womit sie mich schon auch ein bisschen begeistern hätten können, wäre, wenn sie jetzt gesagt hätten, pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt überall USB-C. Und jetzt gibt es auch die iPhones mit USB-C-Charger und nicht mit diesem Lightning-Gedöns.
Das ist ja alles Lightning, das hab ich mir noch gar nicht bewusst geworden.
Thunderbolt und Lightning.
Das ist gut.
Ich wäre Freund von alles USB-C, dann macht das wenigstens Sinn.
Ja, das haben wir uns jetzt eingetreten, dieses USB-C, das geht nicht mehr weg.
Ich hab keinen einzigen USB-C, ich hab jetzt zwei Kabel gekauft für euch.
Obwohl, ich muss sagen, außerhalb der Apple-Welt geht niemand so All-In-USB-C wie Apple, hat man das Gefühl.
Selbst bei Lenovo bieten sie, glaube ich, bei diesem einen High-End-Produkt ein USB-C, worüber du auch laden kannst, aber auch ein USB-A-Port.
Ich sehe jetzt dauernd Leute, die Android-Fones mit USB-C-Charger haben.
Und die lassen sich auch über Apple-Netzteile laden.
War also wirklich dieser Lightning-Connector so schön und schnuffig, der sich anfühlt, aber es macht jetzt so in diesem Ökosystem für mich null Sinn, jetzt extra für die zwei Geräte da wieder ein extra Kabel und... Naja, aber diesen Lightning-Connector werden sie wahrscheinlich noch die nächsten drei Jahre durchschleifen.
Hält dann halt mal so zehn Jahre so eine Lösung. Also, ich finde...
Ja, ich bin jetzt auch kein... Dass da jetzt Lightning dran ist, das stört mich jetzt am wenigsten.
Es wäre einfach mehr convenient. Kannst halt in jeden Laden rennen, wenn du einen Netzteil vergessen hast. Kaufst du ja irgendeinen USB-C-Kabel-Peng fertig. Zum Beispiel hatte mein Segellehrer bei einem der Trips, sein Ladekabel war total zerschrotet. Er ist an den nächsten Ort, wo wir angelegt haben, rein, hat irgendwie einen Laden gesucht. Keiner hatte da eben so ein Lightning-Kabel rumliegen. Letztendlich ist er glücklicherweise auf die Idee gekommen, dass er sein iPhone X da auch in Doktionsladen kann. Er hat sich dann so ein Samsung 0815 in Doktionslade-Insel gekauft und konnte dann damit immerhin laden. Das ist ja auch universell. Das war doch hier auch dieses Kommentar von Steve Jobs, als er da zurückkam und meinte, Apple muss jetzt hier mal aufhören, hier so seine eigenen Adapter- und Connector-Inseln und Protokoll-Inseln zu bauen, sondern Industriestandards sprechen. Und das könnten sie jetzt hier einfach auch beim iPhone und so mal durchziehen. Ab dafür. Nächstes Jahr vielleicht.
Keine Ahnung, gibt es eine USB-C zu Klinke?
Klar.
Den Kopfhörer?
Sonst machen das die Android. Ich hab nämlich bei dem Urlaub, da hatte ich auch eine Android-Form mit USB-C-Lader und dann hängt da auch so ein weißer Schnuffi dran. Und dann hat er gesagt, Moment, ist das ein iPhone? Ach so, ihr habt das gleiche Problem, alles klar. Ach, den muss ich mir jetzt auch neu kaufen. In meinem kleinen Test-Tel mit dem iPod-Shuffle hatte ich auch immer diesen Adapter aufbewahrt. Ach, der ist jetzt auch weg. Wie viel kostet der? 39,90?
Nee, der kostet glaube ich einen Zehner oder so.
Kannst du den nicht von deiner Firma schenken?
Ja, irgendwie.
Also Klinke, es gibt noch einen Use Case für mich bei Klinke und das war's. Also ich bin wirklich komplett durchkonvertiert zum Bluetooth.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel...
Ich will kein Kabel mehr, irgendwie an meinem Körper haben.
Es gibt Geräte, die haben kein Bluetooth. Mixer zum Beispiel.
Ja, im professionellen Umfeld habe ich das natürlich hier auch.
Da hat er ja XLR.
Nein, große kleine Klinker hast du. Also Mixer hast du große Klinker. Das ist auch keine Mini-Klinke. Mixer mit Mini-Klinke ist...
Zum Einspielen, Digga.
Pitzel, Pitzel, Krab.
Du willst was reinmixen von deinem Telefon zum Beispiel.
Ach, das machst du regelmäßig oder was? In deinem Telefon.
Wir sitzen im Proberaum, steht so ein Mixer mit einer PL rum, machen gerade Pause, wollen mal eine Aufnahme hören. Hört man nicht über die kleinen Lautsprecher, schließt man eine Klinke an.
Machst du so einen Bluetooth-Zuklinke?
Ja genau, so sehe ich aus, ja.
Die sind aber meistens Bluetooth-Zukinchen.
Und ich glaube, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war deine Meinung noch schlechter.
Oder?
Ja, dass die nicht gut sind, ist eh klar.
Es gibt immer mal so Situationen. Genau dann zum Beispiel noch so eine Situation. Boot getartert, älteres Boot, hatte ein Autoradio drin, um die Anlage da im Boot zu bespielen. Und wie war der Anschluss? Mini-Klinke für externe Zuspielungen, yeah!
Naja, das ist halt immer noch real.
Gut, dann machen wir jetzt mal den Apple-Kram hier mal zu. Jetzt haben wir ja gar nicht mehr so viel.
Ist ja auch schon spät.
Weil der Huckel wollte noch mal zum...
Kann, muss nicht.
Du warst doch aus Segeln.
Das stimmt.
Ja, hast aber bestimmt wieder richtig abgenerdet.
Na ja, teilweise. Weil, wie schon gesagt, zum Beispiel das Boot, das ich chartete, etwas älter war, war dort kein AIS-Transceiver und nicht mal ein Receiver mit eingebaut. Und AIS ist quasi so... Na ja, wie soll man sagen? Ist so ein Zusatz zum Radar vielleicht. Ist funkbasiert und übermittelt zum Beispiel so den Kurs von Schiffen, was geladen ist, den Namen, die Geschwindigkeit und so weiter und so fort.
Ist das nicht Pflicht?
Für kommerzielle Schiffe. Also alle Containerschiffe, Fähren, Cruiser, alles was Geld verdient mit Schiffverkehr, muss so ein AIS-Transceiver drin haben. Leisure Crafts oder Pleasure Vessels müssen das nicht drin haben. Die meisten Boote, die jetzt so gebaut werden mit dem Equipment, die haben das. Dieses Boot hatte das nicht. Deswegen habe ich mir z.B. einen AIS-Receiver für kleine Münzen gekauft.
Was ist AIS?
Das Information System. Wofür steht das A nochmal? Ich hatte es vorhin hier auf die Wikipedia-Seite. AIS. Software and Technology Automatic Identification System. Das benutzt VHF, um Informationen von Schiffen über Radio zu übertragen.
Achso, damit du dich melden kannst.
Genau. Und die großen Schiffe, die relayen auch Signale von kleineren Schiffen mit geringerer Reichweite. Dann gibt es Basisstationen am Land oder über Satellit, womit das dann in die ganze Welt verteilt wird. Wenn man hier so Schifffeinde, das gibt es so ähnlich wie Flight, Raider oder Marine Traffic, genau, die sind dann so Aggregatoren von diesen ganzen Informationen. Dann sieht man halt den ganzen Schiffsverkehr in der Welt. Und hätte jetzt dieses Boot auch einen Transceiver gehabt, dann hätte man auch da das Boot tracken können. Aber wenn man halt so ein Gerät an Bord hat, dann kriegt man die Daten mehr oder weniger live, also mit wenigen Minuten Verzögerung. Das ist halt gerade bei Nacht oder Nebel oder anderen schlechten Sichtverhältnissen teilweise besser als Radar, weil die kommerziellen Schiffe halt wirklich sagen, ich bin Containerschiff, ich fahre so und so schnell auf dem Kurs. Diese AIS Informationssysteme zeigen auch einem an, ob man auf einem Kollisionskurs ist oder nicht. Was der nächste Punkt der Begegnung ist und lauter so Sachen. Das wollte ich zumindest für Nachtfahrten haben, deswegen habe ich mir dann so einen günstigen AIS Receiver besorgt mit einer Fernsehantenne. Dann hat man zwar eine relativ geringe Reichweite von nur 5 Meilen, aber man konnte dann trotzdem die Informationen von den vorbeifahrenden Schiffen sehen. Das war ganz praktisch. Falls Leute wissen wollen, wie sie selber einen AIS Receiver erwerben können, dann suche ich gerade mal die Webseite raus. Irgendwie lädt die hier bei mir nur sehr langsam. Genau, das war das. Das von dieser Firma hoffentlich auch in den Show Notes. Alles klar. Weil das Coole ist, erstens AIS haben Leute irgendwann mal rausgefunden. Das war natürlich alles so hochproprietär und geschlossenes System. Und irgendwann haben dann aber Leute rausgefunden, also nicht proprietär, aber es war halt nicht so offen und frei verfügbar für kleine Münzen. Dann haben aber Leute rausgefunden, dass AIS auch mit DVB-T-Sticks zu empfangen ist. Weil letztendlich in den DVB-T-Sticks ja auch nur ein Software Defined Radio drin ist. Und haben dann zumindest Receiver mit DVB-T-Sticks gebaut. Und dann haben sich so einige Firmen gegründet, die quasi Low-Cost AIS Receiver bauen. Die beide Kanäle empfangen und dann gleich ein Wi-Fi-Modul drin haben, damit man sich remote mit mehreren Clients quasi an dieses Gerät verbinden kann und kriegt dann diese AIS-Daten reingeströmt. Und dieses Gerät, was ich gekauft habe, das hat auch GPS. Dann bin ich zu Konrad gegangen und hab mir eine GPS-Maus, eine GPS-Antenne gekauft und eine Fernsehantenne, die die richtige Länge hatte für AIS-Signale. Das hat dann bei der einen Nachtfahrt, die wir gemacht haben, ziemlich gut funktioniert. Wie gesagt, fünf Meilen, das ist gerade noch genug, um was zu tun, um dann nicht am Bug dieses großen Schiffes in der Nähe zu landen. Wenn man eine fest installierte AIS-Antenne hat, dann hat man eine Reichweite bis zu 20 Meilen, real 10. Das ist dann schon ein bisschen komfortabler. Das war das eine Nerd-Projekt. Wenn Leute das dann benutzen wollen und nicht wissen wie, also es gibt auf dem iPhone die Applikation iSailer, die mit allerlei Geräten sprechen kann, die Daten über das standardisierte NMA-Protokoll rauspusten. Ich persönlich mag iSailer nicht so sehr zur Navigation, weil ich die Karten nicht so toll finde. Aber es ist eine der wenigen Applikationen, die mit viel externer Hardware an Booten interfacen kann. Zur Navigation habe ich dann eher das Navionics benutzt. Navionics hat wiederum sehr detaillierte Karten und sehr aktuelle Karten. Die muss man auch bezahlen, wie auch bei iSailer. Blöderweise weigern Navionics, die sich standhaft mit jeder großen Version mit dieser ganzen Hardware zu interfacen, weswegen man dann am Ende zwei hat. Was ich dann gemacht habe, war auf meinem Mac OpenCPN zu installieren. OpenCPN ist Open Source Navigationssoftware für die Schifffahrt, womit man dann auch kommerzielles Kartenmaterial reinladen kann. Da hatte ich mal einen der wenigen Nerd-Momente seit Langem wieder. Denn ich habe mir teuer, ich glaube für 150 Euro, Kartenmaterial für das Mittelmeer gekauft, digitales, und es dann hoch derämifiziert und abgesichert, und man kann das nicht so einfach reinladen. Dann muss man halt in dieser Open Source Software, da gibt es dann so Plugins, die dann die ganze Krypto machen, man muss dann Fingerprints und Keys generieren und das mit diesen rottigen Kartenstores austauschen. Dann hatte ich das irgendwann alles fertig, versuche dieses Kartenmaterial in dieses OpenCPN reinzuladen, und was passiert? Crash, Segmentation Fault, das ganze Ding zerlegt sich. Okay, und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich hatte jetzt gerade schon sowieso ein bisschen Projektpause, dann gucken wir doch mal in diesen Stack Trace, der im Apple Crash Report rein, mal sehen, ob man da irgendwas sieht. Naja, dann war das in dem rottigen WX-Widgets, dieser UI-Bibliothek aus, weiß nicht, welchen Dekaden. Und irgendwie kann das aber auch aus diesem Plugin auch was diese Karten entschlüsselt. Dann hab ich irgendwie gesehen auf der Webseite von dem Plugin, dass es eine viel neuere Version schon gibt, als OpenCPN auf ihrer Webseite raus tun. Und dann dachte ich mir, alles klar, gehe ich auf GitHub, klone ich mir den Code, compile mir das mal selber, mal sehen, was passiert. Naja, dann war das mit CMake irgendwie eingerichtet und ich bin ja nicht so ein ultra-Kompilier-Nerd, musste ich mich erstmal in CMake reinfummeln und dann irgendwie die Dokumentation für Apple war natürlich Null und von vor fünf Jahren. Für Linux gab es da so einen schönen Klick-Fahrt. Da musste ich mir also den ganzen Kompilierungsfahrt da zusammen puzzeln, dann war das gebaut, dann habe ich es ins OpenCPN reingeladen, dann meinte das OpenCPN, also im Moment mal, unsere Plugin-ARP ist Version 1.18 und dieses Plugin halt 99,999 als ARP-Version geht nicht, ist nicht kompatibel. Okay, alles klar, jetzt muss ich da irgendwie durchstiefeln, durch dieses Makefile und irgendwo gucken, wo dann dieses Version-Flag gesetzt wird. Naja, sagen wir mal so, die Lösung des Rätsels war dann, dass ich OpenCPN am Ende auch von Hand kompiliert habe, weil das dann meinen Library-Fart, also beide den gleichen Library-Fart benutzt hatten, weil es sich dann rausstellte, dass am Ende die Get-Text-Version von selbst kompiliert und die Get-Text-Version von irgendwas, weiß schon, ne? Der ganze Software-Wahnsinn. Aber als ich beides dann lokal kompiliert hatte, Plug-In reingeladen. Okay, OpenCPN startete, das Plug-In hat geladen und dann, der magische Moment, lädt jetzt auch die Karte tatsächlich und sie lud. Und dann hatte ich echt so geil einen halben Tag lang durch diesen Open-Source-Sumpf einmal durchgefräst. Nicht beim Stacktrace gesagt, okay, drauf geschissen, nicht über mein Geld zurück, sondern so richtig, bis es geht, weiter durchgewieselt. Da war ich ganz stolz, dass es geklappt hat. Und dann war nämlich die Nachtfahrt am Ende so, dass ich auf dem Navigationstisch hatte, ich mein Laptop mit diesem AIS und OpenCPN-Kartenmaterial. Das heißt, wenn die Leute, die da Nachtschicht hatten, eine Frage hatten, ob das Licht da in der Ferne wohl ein Containerschiff auf Kollisionsgruß ist, dann konnten sie mal kurz unter Deck gehen, auf mein Laptop schauen und genau sehen, aus welchem Land kommt das, wo fährt das hin, ist das auf Kollisionsgruß oder nicht. Und oben lag dann das iPad mit so einem Wasserschutzcase, wo dann Navionics drauf lief für die Navigation. Und das hat sehr gut funktioniert. Ja, ich würde es wieder tun. Und dann die letzte Etappe in oder das letzte Nerd-Thema ist eigentlich noch so Wetter. Weil jetzt so in England zum Beispiel das Met Office, das macht eigentlich ziemlich korrektes Wetter. In Deutschland war ich bisher immer so Meteo Group, Weather Pro mäßig ganz zufrieden. Aber wenn man dann mal in anderen Ländern ist, dann merkt man auch, dass bestimmte Wetteraggregatoren oder wie auch immer, Herausgeber, Interpretierer oder wie auch immer, gar nicht so genau Bescheid wissen, wie das Wetter dann woanders ist. Und so war es dann auch in Italien, wo die Meteo Group strahlenden Sonnenschein berichtete und wir saßen im Hafen und es schüttete und gewitterte um uns herum. Und ein Kollege hatte dann, oder ein Freund von mir, hatte das Wetter von den Norwegern die ganze Zeit auf seinem Android-Telefon und das war ziemlich akkurat. Und die Norweger hauen, also da gibt es die Wetteragentur und das Staatsfernsehen, die so in Kooperationen das Wetter machen und das auch über eine API raushauen, sodass irgendwie App-Entwickler, ich glaube kostenlos, auch diese API benutzen können, um Wetter-Apps zu machen. Das war schon mal ziemlich cool. Dann habe ich nach dem Urlaub heute auf Twitter gefragt, ob es iOS-Apps gibt, die diese Wetter-Daten auch verwenden. Und dann wurde mir da auch genannt, hier yr.no, die haben auch eine App und so weiter und so fort. Aber irgendjemand hat das dann auch an den Kachelmann weitergeleitet. Oder irgendwie kam dann eine Wortmeldung von Herrn Kachelmann. Und das war eine ziemlich geile Meldung, die ich jetzt für den Urlaub nicht mehr anwenden konnte, aber die ich jetzt auch mit euch im Chat teilen möchte. Denn für Windvorhersagen gibt es eine App, die heißt Predict Wind. Und die Vereine nehmen verschiedenste Wettermodelle, Windmodelle von den Amerikanern, von den Europäern. Und je nach Region, wo man ist, kann man wirklich sich einen super detaillierten Windwellen, Wetterbericht und Weather Routing machen lassen. Das heißt, man kann sagen, ich will zum Beispiel von Spanien nach Madeira und dann kann man Departure Planning machen anhand des Wetters. Und man kann sagen, okay, gib mir mal Zeitfenster innerhalb von drei Stundenintervallen. Und gib mir die optimale Abfahrtzeit anhand des Windes, Wellen, Wetter etc. Und das benutze ich dann meistens mit dem europäischen Modell, weil das dann eben für Europa auch sowieso meistens akkurater ist. Und diese Wetterdaten, die da zum Einsatz kommen, die gibt es auch bei dieser App jetzt zu nutzen. Die heißt Flodge. Keine Ahnung, wer auf diesen Namen gekommen ist.
Flodge, die Domain war wahrscheinlich noch zu haben.
Klickt mal da drauf, Timme, hier, damit wir das mal auf dem Schirm sehen. Und die benutzt halt dieses europäische Wetter-Netzwerk, möchte ich es mal nennen. Und da hat man halt wirklich so ziemlich alles an Informationen. Also man kriegt dann auch sowas wie Wellenhöhe, Wassertemperaturen, maximale Temperatur, minimale Temperatur, gefühlte Temperatur, Luftdruck, Luftfeuchtigkeit, Regen, Wetterwarnung, Sturm etc. Alles drin. Das User-Interface muss ich sagen, da können sie noch ein bisschen, aber es ist schon mal nicht schlecht. Aber es ist wirklich an Daten, also wer so mal Daten haben will, Luftdruckkarten zum Beispiel, die oft sehr schwer nur so Wetter-Apps zu entlocken sind. Also es ist halt wirklich nicht so dieses, ich mach jetzt die Wetter-App auf und dann ist eine schöne, illustrierte Sonne und ein Wölkchen, sondern hier kann man schon relativ in die Tiefe geben. Und das funktioniert mit einer Subscription, weil die Daten gibt es nicht kostenlos. Die Subscription ist aber relativ überschaubar im Preis gewesen. Ich hab's jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf. Steht das hier vielleicht zufällig irgendwo? Wahrscheinlich im App-Store. Der erste Monat ist gratis.
Jahresabonnement kostet 45. 45 Euro?
Also es gibt von dieser Flodge-App auch verschiedene Abstufungen. Also dass ich jetzt diesen Link nicht hereingetan hab, das ist alles, was du an Daten kriegst. Es gibt sozusagen gescopte Apps, die nur sich um das, ist jetzt Regen oder nicht und wie warm ist es, kümmern. Die sind wahrscheinlich dann günstiger in den Abos. Vermute ich jetzt mal.
Was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, dass die App mehrere Vorhersage-Modelle rechnet und du dann in so einer Liste so sehen kannst, an so einem Zeitstrahl, welches Modell gerade was vorhersagt. Und wenn sich die relativ einig sind, dann kann man sich auch sicher sein, dass genau das dann passiert.
Also für Leute, die so richtig Wetterwetter wissen wollen, würde ich mal diese Flodge-Apps zumindest evaluieren. Ich hab das heute erst erfahren, deswegen kann ich euch jetzt noch keine echten Daten oder Erfahrungen geben, aber wie gesagt, für die Wind- und Wellenvorhersage habe ich das in einer anderen App bereits benutzt und war da eigentlich relativ zufrieden mit.
Die Plotz Storm-App ist auch relativ witzig, weil da kannst du halt dann gucken, wo sind Niederschläge, wo sind Blitzeinschläge und so weiter, wo ist gerade Hagel unterwegs und so ein Zeug. Das Hagel ist jetzt hier nirgendwo.
Ja, also das auf jeden Fall das Wetterthema ist vielleicht mit dieser App dann auch beim Segeln gelöst. Und ansonsten kann ich nur sagen, hat alles gut geklappt und hat Spaß gemacht und ich werde es wieder tun.
Gab es irgendeine Situation, wo du nervös warst?
Klar, mir zum Beispiel die Nachtfahrt, weil irgendwann muss ich halt auch mal pennen und dann muss man halt die ganzen unerfahrenen Leute da so in ihre Schichten machen lassen und versuchen...
Hast du überhaupt geschlafen die Nacht?
Ja, doch. Ich habe aber auf Deck gepennt die meiste Zeit. Also ich habe mich dann auf eine der Sitzflächen mit meinem Schlafsack gepackt und dann, wenn sie dringende Fragen haben, dann war der Dienstweg zumindest sehr kurz. Aber ich habe tatsächlich auch geschlafen bei der Nachtfahrt, aber das war auf jeden Fall einer der Dinge, wo ich dachte so, ich weiß nicht ob das, naja wird schon. Und buddeln auch. Und dann, als wir von Corsica nach Sardinien rüber gefahren sind, da war schon richtig ordentlich Wind und auch schon vergleichsweise gute Welle fürs Mittelmeer und dann waren ja da auch so ein, zwei Leute dabei, die noch nicht so viel Segelerfahrung hatten, die haben dann auch erstmal sich umgeguckt, ob das dann jetzt hier alles in normalen Parametern verläuft. Und da dachte ich mir dann auch so, ok, ich hab jetzt hier die Verantwortung für den ganzen Laden und hoffentlich klappt das jetzt hier gut mit dem sportlichen Überfahren. Ich weiß nicht, es war Windstärke 5 oder sogar schon 6. Also für Leute, die gerne segeln, ist 5 oder 6 so der Wohlfühlbereich. Da kann man halt so ein Boot mal richtig fahren lassen. Für Leute, die eher so an Planche-Urlaub interessiert sind und leger im Mittelmeer rumschippern und mal in der Bucht anhalten und so. Leute gibt es schon auch, gerade die älteren Herrschaften glaube ich, sind nicht so auf das sportliche Segeln aus. Und da ist dann 5 oder 6 schon ein bisschen anstrengender. Also da wurden auch ein paar Leute ein bisschen blasser im Gesicht an den Wort. Also wenn man halt Dinge das erste Mal alleine macht, also zum Beispiel das erste Mal, wenn man dann nach dem Führerschein machen, das erste Mal mit Mamas Auto oder so alleine dann unterwegs und so, okay, ich mach das jetzt hier so einparken und so, bist du schon. Und ja, das erste Mal dann mit einem Boot und 5 anderen Leuten, für die man verantwortlich ist, dann die ganzen Sachen zu machen, ist aufregend. Das erste Mal ablegen, das erste Mal anlegen, diese ganzen Momente, irgendwann hat sich das auch ein bisschen normalisiert. Ankern, auch total aufregend, weil hält der Anker oder hält er nicht? Funktioniert der Anker-Alarm, funktioniert er nicht?
Anker-Alarm ist, wenn was abreißt.
Ja, du ankerst halt, du lässt den Anker runter und setzt dann auf dem GPS einen Radius und diesen Radius verlässt dann Piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep. Aber der Anker hat sehr gut gehalten. Er hat kein einziges Mal uns im Stich gelassen. Und es war ein guter Delta-Anker. Gut dimensionierter Anker, Delta-Anker mit einer gut dimensionierten Kette. Ja, das bei Charter-Unternehmen nicht unbedingt gegeben, dass die da ordentliches Ankermaterial reintun. Kann man wieder machen. Ja, das Geile war in Italien, da musste ich dann in einem Marina so ein Formular ausfüllen. Und dann stand da, statt Schiffsführer oder Skipper, stand da ein Kommandante. Dann musste ich mal kurz schmunzeln, guck dir die Sachbearbeiterin da im Marina-Office an. Ja, Leute sagen jetzt hier fünf oder sechs ist schon, auch vier, also sechs ist schon dann auch die Grenze. Ich glaube, wir waren eher so bei fünf. Wie gesagt, für mich wäre es perfekt gewesen, mit einer gut so im Saft stehenden Crew, hätte man da sehr viel Spaß mit so durchmischt und so. Okay, wie machen wir das jetzt am angenehmsten? Segelfläche kleiner und dann...
Ist ein bisschen anstrengend, um es allen möglichst komfortabel zu machen.
Aber es war okay, also die haben sich da schon alle gut mit arrangiert und unser Noob sozusagen an Bord, auch der Bootsälteste sozusagen, der hat sich da auch ganz gut reingefunden, hat dann auch erst mal so ach lustig, jetzt spritzt hier so ein bisschen Wasser. Huch, jetzt bin ich ganz nass, ich ziehe mich mal um, okay, dann hat er sich dann doch mal die Regenjacke angezogen und dann saß er da auch ganz gut unterhalten glaube ich dann zum Schluss. Aber ich glaube dieser erste Moment, wo dann erst die ersten Spritzer so über Deck kamen, so ach ja, witzig, jetzt segeln wir immer so richtig, weil davor sind wir ganz viel mit dem Motor gefahren, weil kein Wind war und dann kam so die erste, die erste Welle, die erste größere.
Das kann man doch wahrscheinlich eh nur mit einem Lächeln entgegennehmen.
Das ist Mittelmeer, das Wasser hat da 26, 27 Grad im Spätsommer, also da ist jetzt auch keiner direkt am Frieren und Kälte Schock bekommen.
Was sind denn die Nachttemperaturen gewesen? Wenn du sagtest, du hast draußen gepennt, immer noch so 15 Grad?
Ich würde sagen mehr. Echt?
Da war ich ja richtig komfortabel.
Also ich habe mir kurz vor dem Urlaub noch auf Amazon einen batteriebetriebenen Ventilator gekauft. Und das war die Anschaffung, das Gadget des Segelurlaubs. Ohne die wäre ich gestorben in dieser Kabine. Also das war wirklich ein Traum. Weil ich habe dann dieses Fenster innen aufgeklappt und die Scharniere waren so schwergängig, dass ich den Ventilator direkt an das hochgeklappte Fenster kleben konnte. Das heißt, er hat dann die Luft direkt von außen reingesogen und über meinen gebräunten Körper verteilt. Hier fragt gerade einer noch eine Produktfrage hier. Die Amazon Affiliate Link Opportunity für Tim. Das war das iPad Mini Case, was ich verwendet habe. Es hat das iPad erfolgreich vor Seewasserspritzern und Dreck geschützt. Macht einen guten Eindruck. Und wer jetzt noch wissen will, mit welchem Ventilator ich meinen Kopf kühlte. Der Ventilator ist jetzt nicht so der Oberburner, aber die Batterie hat sehr lange gehalten und hat in entscheidenden Situationen die nötige Abkühlung gebracht. Den gibt es hier, weitere Affiliate Link Opportunity. Ja, und dann kann ich nur noch sagen...
Den hatte ich ja auch immer.
Ja, es gibt da...
Oh, mit so einer Klemme.
Ja, die ist auch sehr gut, mit Schaumstoff und so. Die macht auch keine Kratzer. Aber diesen Ventilator-Typ, den gibt es von 23 anderen Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Enterprises China-Buden. Ich hab jetzt den mit den zwei Akkus genommen, die wirklich auch sehr lange gehalten haben.
Ich hab mir kurz bevor der Sommer richtig heiß wurde einen Dyson-Ventilator gekauft.
Das hab ich knapp verpasst, diese Opportunität.
Weil irgendwie, in der Firma haben wir so... Da gibt es immer so Mitarbeiterangebote, wo irgendwelche Firmen irgendwelche Random-Produkte irgendwie bildiger anbieten. Und dann gab es diesen Dyson-Tisch, also das heißt ja eher einen Bodenventilator, irgendwie mit 20 Prozent.
Den runden oder den länglichen?
Den runden.
Aber ohne Filter wahrscheinlich?
Doch, mit Filter.
Echt? Du hast ja einen HIPAA-Unaktiv-Filter.
Ja, mit Filter.
Aber jetzt hast du ja so einen Filter-Abo dir auch noch dazu geklickt quasi.
Nee, einen zweiten Filter hab ich noch dazu geklickt.
Der kostet ja irgendwo smarte...
Nee, der ist es nicht. Der ist es nicht, einer mit einer etwas größeren Öffnung, glaube ich. Nee, nee, der ist es nicht.
Bist du denn sicher, dass er auch den HIPAA-Filter und so weiter hat?
Da, dieser Amazon-Choice, der war es, glaube ich.
Ja, der hat nämlich nicht den Filter.
Nee, dann ist es nicht. Na egal, auf jeden Fall. Da wird man dann schon auch so zum Ventilator-Snob. Besonders weil der Ventilator hat halt eine Fernbedienung. Die irgendwie so ein bisschen abgerundet ist, sodass, und die hat Magneten, und kann man halt obendrauf auf die Rundung tun, weil da auch nochmal Magneten sind. Das Einzige, was an der Fernbedienung nervig ist, sie ist Infrarot. Man muss tatsächlich zielen, damit man dann auch trifft und der reagiert.
Ja, die können halt nur Ventilatoren bauen, nicht?
Das bin ich von Fernbedienungen irgendwie nicht mehr gewohnt. Besonders, wenn man diese Apple TV Fernbedienung, die irgendwie sonst wie funktioniert, kennt. Aber ansonsten... Also... Genau, mit Sleep-Timer-Funktion und diesen ganzen Scheiß.
Ich bin ja als der Sommer so richtig... Also ich sitze ja jedes Jahr dieses Ding aus, so Ventilator kaufen. Ich hatte lange Zeit so einen metallenen Papstlüfter, den sie so in Lüftungsrohre sonst einsetzen. So ein ultraleises, schweres Ding mit 220 Volt. Da habe ich mir dann so relativ krude von einem Nerd im Club Widerstände einlöten lassen, damit er dann ein bisschen langsamer läuft. Und das hat jahrelang... Das war mein Traum. Der macht so einen leichten Zug, super flüsterleise, hat man nicht gehört. Den habe ich mir ein paar Meter vom Bett weggestellt und der hat genau gereicht, um so diese Verdunstungskühle hinzubekommen. Dann war der irgendwann kaputt. Dieses Jahr dachte ich so, okay, fuck it, ich habe jetzt drei Nächte nicht gepennt, ich brauche jetzt einen Ventilator. Ich bin zu Konrad, bin zu Karstadt, bin zu Bauhaus, wo sonst sich die Ventilatoren vor dem Sommer stapelten. Bei Konrad gab es noch einen, so einen kleinen, mit so Textilpropeller-Dingsbumms, der auch sehr gut war, aber das war wirklich so, oh Gott, wäre ich jetzt drei Stunden später hier reingelaufen, wäre ich wahrscheinlich den ganzen Sommer schwitzend im Bett gelegen.
Diesen Moment habe ich verpasst, da ich mein Schlafzimmer in wunderschöner Südseite habe, wo ich nicht nur nicht schlafen kann, nein, ich arbeite in dem Zimmer halt dann halt auch, da kann ich halt auch nicht arbeiten. Ich hab zum Glück ja zwei Schreibtische, einen wirklich so als Schreibtisch, Schreibtisch und einen halt so Nähtisch. Ich musste dann in der Tat zu meinem Nähtisch flüchten, damit ich so ein bisschen im Schatten sitzen kann. Und so nur bei 27 oder vielleicht auch nur bei 28 Grad Schwitze.
Du kannst vorne und hinten Fenster aufmachen, dann hast du Durchzug.
Oh ja, dann sind die 27 Grad, denn ansonsten sind es 29.
Du hast nur 29? Ich habe in meiner Südseite Kreuzberger Südhang in diesem Sommer schon auf über 30 geschafft.
Boah, das hab ich zum Glück nicht geschafft. Aber wenn ich einzig, ich mach mir gleich mal ein Reminder in den Kalender, dass ich im Dezember einen scheiß blöden Lüfter kaufe, damit ich nicht wieder das Problem habe im Sommer.
Nee, das war echt ein Glücksgriff, genau bevor es richtig heiß wurde. Aber es ist trotzdem auch nicht kühl geworden irgendwie. Ich hab halt nicht die vorne-hinten-Fenster-Situation, sondern so in der Ecke im Innenhof.
Dann kann man nur hoffen, dass man schnell genug schwitzt um diese Verdunstungskühe.
Da hab ich dann auch wirklich mal mit offenem Fenster geschlafen, was, wenn man in der Nähe vom Flughafen wohnt, eigentlich keine so tolle Idee ist. Ruhpacks. Weil um halb zwölf, glaube ich, das letzte normale reguläre Flugzeug reinkommt und dann um halb zwei nochmal das Postflugzeug und das erste Flugzeug aber um sechs Uhr morgens wieder startet. Also da muss man dann irgendwie, ja, entweder halb taub sein oder hart im Nehmen gehen.
Ich werd langsam müde.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich sitz auch hier schon seit fünf Stunden.
Ja, dann lass uns doch aufhören.
Mit acht Stunden sitz ich jetzt hier.
Nur noch ein kleiner Nachtrag, weil ich gerade nochmal nachgeschaut hab. Es waren tatsächlich Windstärke sechs, also schon ordentlich. War vier bis fünf angesagt und dann waren sechs.
Eine Kleinigkeit, die ich auf jeden Fall noch sagen wollte, ich war ja beim Guitar Dog mit meiner Gitarre.
Was heißt das?
Guitar Dog ist so ein Gitarrenbauer in Kreuzberg, der...
Mit legendärem Status.
Mit legendärem Status, der anbietet die Gitarre einmal quasi einstellungsmäßig noch mal Grund zu überholen. Und das hat sich schon echt gelohnt. Also erstens hat er die Seitenlage so angepasst, dass sie wirklich optimal ist, lässt sich deutlich leichter spielen, weil die Seiten jetzt nicht mehr so hoch sind. Und zweitens, ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass es so geht. Also er hat auch die Tonabnehmer in der Höhe so eingestellt, dass die nicht mehr so stark unterschiedlich sind von der Lautstärke, was der Output ist. Also ich bin ganz zufrieden.
Also jeder, der eine Gitarre hat oder Gitarren interessiert ist und in Berlin oder in der Nähe wohnt, oder wenn ihr mal in Berlin seid, geht mal ruhig beim Gitarre-Doc vorbei, auch wenn ihr vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt ein Problem mit der Gitarre habt. Der Laden, den kann man sich einfach mal kurz anschauen und dann auch weiterlaufen. Das ist wirklich einer der schönsten so Locations für so eine Werkstatt. Der ist direkt an der Spree in so einem grünen Hinterhof. Also diesen Laden, wenn ich... Also ich hätte genau diesen Laden genauso ganz gerne mit den ganzen alten Verstärkern und diesen ganzen Gitarren und der ist auch immer eigentlich ganz redselig, wenn er nicht gerade busy ist.
Die waren super busy, die hatten überhaupt keinen Bock irgendwie. Ja gut, das erste Mal war ich auch irgendwie fünf Minuten bevor sie zugemacht haben da. Und das zweite Mal, ja, naja, gut.
Also ich geh meistens immer vormittags rein, weil da sind sie irgendwie immer noch... Oder kurz nach der Mittagspause sind sie meistens noch so ein bisschen im Gesprächsmodus. Hängt aber ein bisschen davon ab. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt so große Gitaristen in der Stadt sind, wie zum Beispiel auch der Joe Bonamassa oder so, die kennen dann auch mal bei dem Herren ein und lassen sich da vielleicht nochmal was einstellen oder reparieren. Der ist wirklich ganz cool. Ist nicht der einzige in dieser Stadt, aber schon...
Doch, das war auf jeden Fall ein guter Tipp.
Als ich meine Gitarre selber zusammengebaut hab, war ich ja dann mit der Einstellung erstmal so halb zufrieden. Dann hab ich's zu ihm gebracht, um nochmal so das Final... den Final Pass zu machen, danach war das auch wie... also von einer okayen Gitarre zu einer richtig guten Gitarre.
Nee, das war irgendwie... Ansonsten an der Gitarre war ja so nichts dran, obwohl die jetzt auch schon irgendwie 20 Jahre alt ist oder so, oder 25, weiß nicht genau. Zum Thema Podstock, weiß nicht, ist jetzt schon zu weit her. Oder sollen wir da drüber noch kurz was sagen?
Wir da waren...
Dir hat's nicht so gefallen, ne? Du warst aber auch nicht so involviert.
Ich war jetzt nicht so involviert. Ich hab das mit Interesse verfolgt. Ich hab jetzt nichts Schlechtes drüber zu sagen.
Also die Kochcrew war großartig. Das muss man einfach mal so sagen. Sie nennen sich ja nicht umsonst das Eternal Buffet, weil die so Frühstückmittagessen, Abendessen so ineinander verlief. Weil irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht so genau, warum eigentlich, aber es hörte nie auf mit dem Essen.
Das ist das Beste.
Und dann haben wir natürlich diese große Aktion. Ich hab...
Du solltest nochmal erwähnen, wovon du redest.
Also das Podstock ist ein, kann man das Festival nennen? Festival-Barcamp-Camp-Veranstaltung, wo Podcaster hingehen und ein paar Hörer waren auch da. Und mit Bühne und noch einem Podcast-Raum, wo man noch Aufnahmen machen konnte, so in der Art. Also, äh, was waren's? 80 Leute, glaube ich.
Ja, es ist ein Community-Treffen.
Genau, ein Community-Treffen, könnte man sagen. Genau, und dann?
Dieser Pampa.
Äh, ziemlich in der Pampa, ja. Ziemlich in der Pampa. Also, äh, lustigerweise, die hatten irgendwie geplant, Pizza zu machen und hatten 20 Kilo Mehl gekauft. Aber niemand hatte sich so recht überlegt, wie denn das jetzt so geht mit so einem Pizzateig und so. Und dann meinte ich so, ja, Pizzateig kein Problem, mach ich. Das war so ein bisschen ein Fehler, weil irgendwie mit 20, 22 Kilo Mehl, 16 Liter Wasser, 350 Gramm Salz. Sag mal, der Bizeps.
Hast du mit der Bohrmaschine geknetet?
Nee, natürlich mit der Hand. Aber wir waren zu zweit. Das war, und dann, und das war eigentlich eine total geile Aktion. Weil die hatten so einen Lebenofen im Garten. Den haben wir halt dann mit Holz angeheizt. Und dann haben wir den ganzen Belag, alles so auf zwei Bierbänkentischen, alles hintereinander aufgereiht. Und dann konnten sich die Leute halt ein Holzbrett nehmen und ein bisschen Teig und konnten dann anfangen, halt ihre Pizza zu machen. Ausrollen, Tomatensoße drauf, Käse und den gesamten Belag usw. Und dann haben wir das Zeug dann in den Ofen geschoben. Das war super aufwendig, aber ich glaube, das haben irgendwie alle ziemlich geil gefunden. Und dieser Teig wurde nicht weniger, weil er die ganze Zeit gegangen ist. Er war da in dieser riesen Kiste drin und sie wurde einfach nicht weniger.
Das stimmt, das war üppig.
Wir hatten übrigens auch auf dem Segelboot Sauerteig dabei und haben, also Italien ist ja auch nicht viel Brot bekannt, haben wir richtig geiles Brot auf dem Boot gebacken. Brot auf dem Boot.
Tim, da ist doch mal was, da ist doch Raum für Verbesserung im Wohnwagen.
Was, wo bist du jetzt gerade?
Na, bei Brotbacken.
Wir sind jetzt im Erata-Bereich. Miskelemies, Kapitelmarke, Sonstiges.
Ich bin durchgenommen.
Na gut, dann lassen wir das für heute.
Ihr nicht, oder was?
Doch, ich freu mich jetzt gleich ins Bett zu treten.
Oh ja, eine Uhr, ich glaube jetzt kann man das.
Ja, das war jetzt schon mehrfache Überlänge. Ich würd sagen, wir machen das mal.
Eigentlich nicht, aber wir haben halt zu früh angefangen.
Ja, aber wir haben ja auch vorher schon zwei Stunden geguckt. Ja, ich bin auch immer schon ein paar Stunden vorher hier. Der Tag war lang. Ich äh... Ich mach mal das mit der Musik hier.
Ja, tü tü tü tü.
Das war's jetzt, sehr viel mehr gibt es erst mal nicht.
Ich hoffe ihr seid begeisterter von den Apple Produkten als wir.
Ich finde die gut. Mal gucken was wir bis zum nächsten Mal schon alle gekauft haben. Bis bald!
Tschüssi!
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.
Guck, ich hab neues Feature hier, wenn ich lache, dann Emoji lacht auch. Siehst du, Stück Scheiße lacht auch.
Wieso Debil?
Ich versteh, hat man euch allen ins Gehirn geschissen, ihr seid froh darüber. Der arme Wichser geht 24 Stunden arbeiten, 8 Euro pro Stunde verdient er, damit er sich endlich dieses Scheiß Ding kaufen kann und dann kauft er sich diesen Huren so ein Sieben, ist froh, als ob sein Schwanz 3 Meter lang ist, kommt nach Hause, macht den Fernseher an und dann steht der Bastard im schwarzen Pullover, sagt, herzlichen Glückwunsch, ich kann dir nun gratulieren, wir haben das Huren so ein 8 erfunden, das wird die Welt verändern. Und dann denkt er sich, blöd, wie soll ich mir das verdienen, wie lange soll ich das arbeiten gehen, damit ich mir das kaufen kann. Und dann noch meiner Freundin muss ich auch eins kaufen, die wird mir das nie verzeihen, dass ich ein altes hab, die wird das mit dem Hammer kaputt machen. Komm mal her, weißt du was das bedeutet, das Logo? Lass mich mal dahinsetzen, weißt du was dieses Logo bedeutet? Ich weiß nicht was das bedeutet. Soll ich dir mal die Geschichte erzählen? Von der Sünde, aus dem Paradies der abgebissene Apfel. Weißt du was das heißt? Was das heißt? Eva hat den Apfel abgebissen und wurde von der Schlange gefickt und das gleiche wird mit ihr auch passieren.
Ich will nicht von der Schlange gefickt werden, Mensch.
Das ist der Schlange scheißegal, die kontrollieren alles. Kennst du die Illuminati? Nein, kenn ich nicht. Die beleuchtet machen den, weil ihr wie Sklaven mit diesen scheiß Emojis behandelt werdet, anstatt intelligente Bücher zu lesen. Kennst du David Rockefeller? Nein, kenn ich nicht. Natürlich kennst du den nicht. Der hat sich sechs Herzen transplantieren lassen. Und wenn du bei McDonalds was kaufen gehst, dann zack, kriegt er einen Cent überwiesen. Und wenn du dir dieses scheiß iPhone kaufst, dann kriegt er sich das siebte Herz, wird ihm implantiert. Der Hakan ist extra aus Istanbul angereist, hat zehn Tage vor dem Apple Store gestanden, hat gefroren, hat beide Nieren sich abgefroren. Na und? Das ist so scheißegal, der hat sich zwei Shisha-Kohlen anstatt transplantieren lassen, kann nur noch mit dem mit Shisha atmen, normal. Aber das ist nicht, weil das wird dir helfen, dein rechtes Ei sich transplantieren zu lassen.
Alter, du hast doch selber iPhone 6.
Psychopath!